Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, jetzt so nach der Wahl, hättest du nicht ein paar politische Schönheitstipps für mich.
Ja, die sind doch alle auf dem Flyer. Hast du den nicht bekommen?
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer 408 vom 4. Oktober 221. Der,
Nationalfeiertag liegt hinter uns und auch die Wahl, die weiß ich nicht äh.
Auch so ein Nationalfeiertag war, auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise vielleicht auch nicht. Äh würde ich sagen, werden wir auf jeden Fall heute nochmal äh drüber reden.
Ja und äh du möchtest bestimmt auch nochmal wieder einen HTTP Fehlercode kurz berichten, oder?
Ja, weil wir ja äh die Nummer 408 am Start haben und ihr wisst ja, euer kleiner Exkurs.
Und das ist eigentlich auch was sehr schönes. Ich äh bin ja auch ein großer Freund vom äh Time-out oder auch Tim Out, wie manche Leute sagen.
Und 408 request time out
dass äh passiert, wenn wenn der Server die Hoffnung in dich verliert irgendwie, wenn irgendwie nix mehr passiert und die Beziehung so ein bisschen abeppt und äh dann
dich auf und drop dich.
Deine deine Anfrage ist nicht mehr vollständig geworden, ne?
Ja oder kommt nicht mehr und so weiter, das geht dann irgendwie so hin und her und dann die.
Ist jetzt mal äh wird nicht weiter beantwortet so.
Und irgendwie passt es ganz gut in die Zeit, habe ich so den Eindruck, weil da gab's dann irgendwie noch so einen anderen Request, der auch irgendwie nicht so die richtige Antwort bekam.
85 haben nicht die Antwort bekommen, ja?
Eine also eine Aktion des Zentrums für politische Schönheit, die äh mal wieder,
ihresgleichen sucht, was haben die getan? Die haben eine Webseite gebaut und haben dort eine ein fiktives Unternehmen,
präsentiert und zwar den Flyerservice Hahn. Der Flyerservice Hahn hat es äh hat tatsächlich insgesamt fünfundachtzig AfD,
verbänden, ja? Ähm.
Den den Auftrag abgerungen, Flyer zu verkaufen, äh zu verteilen. Diese Flyer summierten sich in der Summe auf,
Fünf Millionen Flyer, äh die laut Angaben des ZPS insgesamt ein Gewicht von 72 Tonnen haben und die haben,
quasi von all diesen Ortsverbänden diese Flyer sich dann zusenden lassen aus der Druckerei zum Verteilen,
und äh haben die dann einfach nicht verteilt. Was äh ja schon schon.
Ziemlich, ziemlich mutig ist. Ähm vielleicht muss man dazu noch sagen, so üblicherweise ähm haben es Parteien nicht unbedingt nötig
Flyer, Verteiler zu engagieren und diese zu bezahlen, weil das Fußvolk der Partei.
So etwas ja dann selber macht und freiwillig macht, ne? Dafür hast du ja Parteimitglieder, damit die äh Beiträge zahlen, damit du da deine Infrastruktur für die Partei unterhalten kannst.
Und damit ihr am, damit die äh in der die Wahlplakate aufhängen.
Damit die Flyer verteilen und irgendwie die Werbetrommel für dich rühren. Aber die AfD hat da offenbar äh ja insgesamt,
immer nicht so eine so eine so eine Mitwirkungs ähm Motivation, die haben ja eher so eine Meckermotivation und insofern haben sich hier offenbar diese Leute dazu entschieden, eine externes Unternehmen zu beauftragen,
Ich finde die Aktion, also ich meine, die ist halt schon.
Echt mutig, weil da glaube ich auf jeden Fall so einige und ich bin ja jetzt wieder kein Anwalt, ne, aber ich glaube, das darf man nicht.
Könnte sein. Kann Spuren von Illegalität enthalten.
Weil also die haben ja da dieses Unternehmen äh das gab es eben gar nicht, ne. Also es ist irgendwie.
Vortäuschung von irgendwas.
Genau, aber wahrscheinlich wär's jetzt auch nicht unbedingt besser gewesen, wenn's das Unternehmen gegeben hätte, weil am Ende haben sie ja hier Aufträge.
Also Angebote gemacht und Aufträge erhalten in im Rahmen sagen wir mal in einer ganz normalen,
geschäftlichen Tätigkeit, die sie da vorgetäuscht haben und in diesem Fall eben ja vorsätzlich vorgetäuscht haben, mit dem Ziel, diese ähm.
Diese Flyer niemals auszuteilen. Und das ist, denke ich, schon, wenn man das jetzt juristisch betrachtet, glaube ich, sind da so Sachen wie Betrug und Vorsatz ähm durchaus ähm.
Nennenswerte Kategorien, ja. Gleichzeitig ähm,
kommt dann wahrscheinlich auch noch Sachbeschädigung hinzu, weil sie diese Flyer ja jetzt auch nicht zurückgegeben haben, ne, sondern weiß nicht, haben die ja letzte Woche irgendwann einen Container aufgestellt und die Leute dadrin baden lassen.
Oh Mann ey.
Also ich bin ich und ich ich was ich mich wirklich frage ist, also diese ZPS-Aktionen haben ja immer.
Hm, also, was, was die halt besser machen als alle anderen
Kommunikationsgerät Gruppen ist, dass die ja quasi so 'n zweiten und 'n dritten Akt noch drin haben, ja? Der noch kommen wird. Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, was macht die AfD jetzt damit, ja?
Sagen die okay, fuck it, wir klagen die in Grund und Boden, übersehen die mit Strafanzeigen und zivilrechtlichen Klagen, was
was auf jeden Fall eine Möglichkeit ist, ja? Gleichzeitig hast du ja dann auf jeden Fall noch jahrelange
Bericht, Gerichtsprozesse, ja, die die stattfinden, wo jedes Mal dann berichtet wird. Das ZPS hat die Flyer von der AfD weggeworfen, ne. Ähm das heißt, es könnte natürlich sein, dass die AfD versteht, okay
für die paar tausend Euro Schaden, die wir da jetzt hatten, äh können, könnten wir uns jetzt jahrelang zum Gespür der Leute machen,
Es kann aber auch sein, dass die AfD auf die Dummheit ihrer Wähler zählen kann ähm und dann sagt, na hier, das ist eine Wahlmanipulation und ein Angriff und das sind hier äh Verfassungsfeinde und hast du nicht äh gesehen. Und daraus halt tatsächlich noch ein ähm,
zumindest politisches Kapital ziehen könnte. Wie würdest du das denn sehen?
Also ist beides möglich. Ich weiß ja jetzt nicht, was das ZBS noch so im äh Köcher hat, so, ne? Kann durchaus sein. Ich meine, in diesem tollen
politischen Schönheitstipps-Video, was sie dazu veröffentlicht haben, was wenn ihr das nicht gesehen habt, die euch unbedingt anschauen solltet, weil also allein dafür ist es schon äh hat sich die Sache schon gelohnt. So äh
ging das ja sogar soweit, dass es dass sie's ja sogar, also sie haben ja auch beschrieben, wie sie das überhaupt geschafft haben, ja, also wie einfach es in gewisser Hinsicht war, der der AfD äh sich da als Geschäftspartner aufzudrängen
was,
im Kern will ich das mal kurz zusammenfassen darf. Du musst die einfach nur loben und preisen irgendwie und geil finden öffentlich so und dann dann, dann, dann denken die sich sofort ab und geben dir irgendwie ihr ganzes Geld. Also sind auch echt ganz schön ganz schön doof drauf,
Ähm und die haben's ja dann sogar geschafft, so Leute auch dann so in den inneren Kreis einzuschleusen. Also das Video deutet das zumindest an und zeigt
und so weiter, ne. Äh kann natürlich auch sehr wohl sein, dass in dem Zuge auch noch Informationen gewonnen werden konnten
von der die AfD jetzt auch nicht unbedingt möchte, dass sie noch weiter an die Öffentlichkeit gezogen wird. Also ist schwierig. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das alles von der Kunstfreiheit gedeckt ist, aber was mich betrifft, äh passt das irgendwie alles soweit erstmal.
Was sehr, also man sollte, das muss man sich wirklich auch alles auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, auf dieser Webseite gibt es auch so ein schönes Testimonials, ne. Das sagen unsere Kunden.
Irgendwie so gemäß Auftrag hätten 10.000 Flyer in der Woche vom 6.9. bis 19 verteilt werden müssen. Dies ist nicht geschehen. Ich habe am Montag, den 1309., wieder 10.000 Flyer zur Verteilung in Neu-Isenburg bei der Spedition angeliefert.
Ich ich kann nur sagen, dass ich von Kreisverbänden gehört habe, dass ihre Firma unter der angegebenen Adresse keine Räumlichkeiten hat und AfD
D-Flyer an der einen Adresse eingeliefert wurden, die dann von einem Herrn im Sportwagen abgeholt wurden,
Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel auch irgendwie sowas Flyer zur Verteilung in Schleswig-Holstein, haben die sich erstmal nach Mainz liefern lassen.
Ist doch schön teuer ist.
Also äh ja, wo wirklich sehr schön und man kann also genau dieses Video sollte man sich auf jeden Fall anschauen.
Und ähm,
also klar sammeln die jetzt Geld. Das ist also die brauchen jetzt auch Geld, weil die garantiert äh also rechtliche Probleme haben, ne.
Aber da gibt's dann sehr schöne äh dafür, ne. Also ähm so Feuerzeuge vom Flyerservice Hahn oder passender Aufkleber.
Das Ding ist halt auch innerhalb kürzester Zeit auch schon so zu einem seinem eigenen Mehm geworden, der,
FC St. Pauli hat's ja nicht nehmen lassen bei seinem Heimspiel gegen ausgerechnet Dresden irgendwie hat er Bandenwerbung mit der FC Sankt Pauli grüßt Flasche Service Hahn zu werben.
Wirklich großartig.
Ist wirklich, also das das ist auch so unglaublich geil, ja. Also das ist,
naja, also in Flyerservice, Hahnshirt, will man schon haben, ja, oder ein Käppi, äh und na ja, alles nicht, alles nicht günstig, klar, ne? Äh es gibt auch noch ähm.
Also wer 1tausend Euro spendet, äh kriegt den Perk Weihnachten mit Höcke,
Äh da war kann man, also darf man ja nicht vergessen, das Zentrum für politische Schönheit ist ja immer noch Nachbarin von Bernd Höcke.
Und die haben immer noch,
diesen Holocaust-Mahn mal nachbaut, bei dem vor der Haustür gestellt, ne? Das sind einfach Dinge, die laufen weiter so, ne? Das ist jetzt schon Jahre her, aber der Mietvertrag ist da so günstig, in Bornhagen oder was, ja? Ähm.
Die kriegen die da nicht rausgeklaut.
Die Versuche des Vermieters, die da rauszuklagen sind halt an Inkompetenz gescheitert,
in der wievielten Instanz, ja, so dass die dann paar hundert Euro halt weiterhin diese Hütte haben. Jetzt weiß ich allerdings nicht, also.
Weihnachten mit Höcke ist halt so eine Sache, ne? Also ich meine ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das halt ne.
Also ich sag mal würde ich nicht, würde ich nicht, würde ich mir nicht jetzt für 'n romantisches Weihnachtswochenende zu zweit auswählen, sondern da würde ich vielleicht eher mit der, mit dem größeren Freundeskreis anreisen und, und
zur Sicherheit ein paar Hunde dabei haben oder so, ne, weil das ist ja so eine Fackelträger äh so ein Fackelträgerdorf, da muss man vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Aber äh ja sehr.
Schön. Also dass das äh so diese den Mut aufzubringen, ja, das durchzuziehen finde ich halt echt äh.
Einfach nur einfach nur geil. Ja, tolle, tolle Aktion. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich die.
Coolste äh politische Aktion,
seit sehr langem. Ja, also mir fällt lange nichts mehr ein. Jetzt kann natürlich auch, okay, jetzt geht's natürlich los so, ja, war das jetzt, ist es irgendwie, ne? Wurde diese Partei jetzt ihrer ähm.
Ihrer Wahlwerbung beraubt und hat die, wo die deswegen nicht gewählt, nee, das denke ich nicht. Also, dass, äh, ich mein, wer jemals wegen eines Flyers gewählt hat oder nicht gewählt hat, äh, ja, müsste schon ziemlich dumm sein, aber gut, jetzt, AfD.
Da werde ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher. Also das das das ist schon so ein Instrument der der Empörungskultur, die dieser Laden betreibt,
ne? Das ist jetzt sicherlich, hängt nicht alles da dran. Viel ist das, was über die Medien abstrahlen und das hat sicherlich nochmal eine sehr viel größere Wirkung, aber man unterschätzt auch schnell diese Mobilisierung über Kanäle, die wir
ähm sagen wir mal auch mit so einer intellektuellen Brille oft so ein bisschen übersehen. Es ist so ein bisschen wie mit diesen Wochenzeitungen.
Meine, du schmeißt die auch gleich weg, ja.
Nee, ich ich haue den Typen kaputt, wenn der die mir im Briefkasten steckt. Der ist ein großes Schild dran, dass ich.
Keine Gewaltandrohungen aller Öffentlichkeit auf jeden Fall äh sagen wir mal so ähm dies äh,
du denkst dir jetzt nicht so, oh
Eine Zeitung, mal schauen, was da Interessantes drinstehen könnte. So und man entsorgt halt auch gemeinhin auch den ganzen anderen Spam, der eben über diese Kanäle äh so kommt, weil es sich halt eigentlich im Wesentlichen immer um Werbung handelt. So
Aber warum gibt es denn diese Wochenzeitung dann überhaupt noch, wenn angeblich alle die wegwerfen? Ne? Und das ist halt das Problem äh generell.
Für uns gar nicht mehr. Ich müsste mal gucken, also entweder haben meine wiederholten, nicht Gewalt an Drogen, aber freundlichen Erinnerungen, dass ich diese Zeitung nicht haben möchte, gewirkt, dass der dass die bei uns im Haus nicht mehr verteilt wird.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, das ist halt.
Das musst du dann halt auch schon aufbringen, ne? Und bei anderen Leuten verfängt das halt einfach und da wird wird das gelesen. So und es wird Werbung gelesen und es wird Werbung auch geguckt und angeschaut auch im Fernsehen.
Und Zeitung lesen.
Ich sage ja nur.
Du hast Recht, die wirken. Das, du hast Recht und ich weiß, dass sogar tatsächlich ähm dass ich mal mit äh,
mit Einzelhändlerinnen gesprochen habe so in
in dem Bereich, in dem ich wohne, ohne dass äh so über Werbemöglichkeiten wir uns da unterhalten, aber das ist jetzt auch über zehn Jahre her, ne? Aber da kamen dann tatsächlich die äh der die Perspektive auf, dass sie sagt, naja, sie hätten vieles probiert und dass das aber wirklich wirkt,
in diesem ja kostenlosen Kiezzeitungen, ja? Das,
die die machen natürlich auch also deren Angebote sind ja schalte eine Anzeige für was weiß ich,
die nächsten drei Ausgaben und äh du bekommst einen redaktionellen Beitrag dazu, ne, dann kommt noch eine kommt eine Journalistin vorbei, macht ein Foto und schreibt einen tollen Text über deinen Laden, ne, also so die arbeiten wir auch mit allen
die jetzt, sage ich mal, in äh gemeinhin äh nicht,
nicht betrachtet würden oder nicht in Betracht geben. Also Vermischung von redaktionellen Inhalten und Werbung, aber ähm.
Ja, da da weiß ich tatsächlich, dass die äh als als einzig wirksame Werbemethode wahrgenommen wurden von den Einzelhändlerinnen.
Ja, das war also eine sehr äh schöne äh Aktion. Nicht ganz so eine schöne Aktion war dann die Wahl in der letzten Woche zumindest, was die Situation in Berlin betrifft, wo sich unsere Hauptstadt mal wieder ähm,
seinen Ruf verteidigt hat. Als Zentrum des allgemeinen Chaos und äh Verwaltungstechnischer,
negativer Höchstleistung. Du warst ja Wahlhelfer, wie wir denn noch kurzfristig erfahren haben. Ich äh,
mich dann ähm an dem Tag noch kurzfristig in den Dienst der Wahlbeobachtung äh gestellt, nachdem ich gemerkt habe, dass ähm bei dem Wahllokal, wo
Ich hätte äh wählen sollen, auch irgendwie eine sehr lange Schlange stand. Ich konnte dann Gott sei Dank auf ein anderes Wahllokal ausweichen, weil ich mir zuvor schon,
Briefwahlunterlagen habe zuschicken lassen, die aber nicht per Post abgeschickt habe, sondern lediglich diesen Wahlschein dann genommen habe, um dann.
Dann kann man nämlich in jedem Wahllokal innerhalb des Wahlbezirks wählen, wie ich dann erfuhr und so muss ich dann eben nicht in dieser langen Schlange stande, aber stand da so und dachte mir so,
irgendwas schief, so was kennst du doch gar nicht. Also das waren so zwei, drei Leute irgendwie davor stehen, klar.
Dass durch Corona irgendwie da ein bisschen mehr Prozedur da vorne ist. Aber es nahm ja da nicht ab und dann bin ich irgendwie am gegen Abend noch mal dahin gefahren. Die Schlangen wurden halt immer noch länger
dachte ich mir so, okay, alles klar, den Prozess, den schaue ich mir jetzt mal genauer an. Ja und zu dem Zeitpunkt und dann sprach sich das ja auch schön rum, dass das jetzt nicht nur äh hier in meinem Wahllokal so war, sondern an ganz vielen Stellen in Berlin
eine ganze Menge schief lief,
nicht nur, dass äh es dauerte, weil zu wenig Wahlkabinen aufgestellt wurden, sondern es kam dann auch noch so Korken dazu, dass.
Keine Wahlzettel mehr verfügbar waren, so die waren dann halt nicht vollständig. Entweder fehlten alle oder es fehlten einige
und dann gab's auch mal Wahllokale, wo einfach die falschen ausgegeben wurden, womit dann 70 Prozent aller Stimmen ungültig waren und so. Also es nahmen überhaupt gar kein Ende. Am Ende bei unserem Wahllokal standen sie dann irgendwie noch um 81 Uhr 45 in der in der Schlange.
Um 8zehn Uhrdreißig kam irgendwie noch mal eine Bullenwatte vorbei und brachte nochmal ein paar Walzzettel, damit's auch reicht. Es ist wirklich ein totales äh Chaos. Wie ist es denn bei dir gelaufen?
Du musst nur ganz kurz sagen, das wird also falsche Wahlzettel haben in Berlin 30.000 Menschen bekommen, wenn ich das richtig gesehen.
30tausend0 oh Gott.
30.tausend sind in Wahllokal gekommen, hallo, herzlich willkommen zur Wahl, hier ist ihr Zettel, zack, haste gewählt, gehst du raus, packen die nachher Zelt aus und falsch, ungültig, ne?
Haha. Gearsch.
Sorry.
Viele Grüße vom Wahlservice Hahn.
Und aber das Krasse ist natürlich, Tim, ähm da haben wir natürlich jetzt auch, haben wir so viel drüber gerätselt, äh.
Merkst du das nicht, ne? Und nee, merkst du nicht, glaube ich auch, weil also doch du merkst das, du hast ja eventuell, also wenn du ein bisschen,
wäre ich in der Situation gewesen, ich bin mir relativ sicher, die mir zum Beispiel die Direktkandidatinnen meines Bezirkes zu kennen. Ja, also ich weiß, wer hier für für die Grünen, für die Linke, äh, angetreten ist, so, naja,
da hätte ich mich wahrscheinlich schon gewundert, wenn die nicht auf dem Zettel stehen für die Bundestagswahl.
Wenn wir hier in äh Bezirksverordnetenversammlung oder Abgeordnetenhaus gehen, da hätte ich das schon nicht mehr gewusst, ja. Das waren ja die anderen beiden,
Stimmen, die oder die anderen drei Stimmen die Berliner abgeben mussten, das heißt da hätte ich's auch nicht gemerkt. Und jetzt kommt der Punkt, wenn ich's gemerkt hätte, stelle ich mir halt auch die Frage,
ich dann in dem Wahllokal wirklich gesagt hätte, Entschuldigung, kann das sein, dass sie den falschen Zettel mir gegeben haben?
So weißt du, wenn ich irgendwie um um sechzehn Uhr wählen gehe und denke so, hm, hier sind, das wird ja hier von Profis gemacht,
ne. Die werden wir jetzt nicht den falschen Zell ergeben. Ich halte mal lieber die Fresse, bevor mich das ganze Wahllokal auslacht, weil äh weil mir weil ich weil ich nicht wusste, wer hier aufm Zelt stehen soll, ne. Insofern, ja, kann ich mir schon sehr gut vorstellen, dass dass so etwas halt dann.
Passiert, ne? Das ist, dass es niemandem auffällt. Äh, wirklich faszinierend, kannst ja, also krass, krasse, krasse Geschichte,
darf natürlich nicht passieren. Wer jetzt gefragt, okay, wie war meine Erfahrung? Äh wir erinnern uns, ich hatte ja schon, also ich hatte ja schon so ein komisches Gefühl, weil ich ja, ich wurde ja am 18. September, also ein paar Tage vorher, äh,
per E-Mail so E-Mail mit einem angehängten PDF noch verpflichtet als Wahlhelfer zu wirken,
ja? Ähm ich meine Rolle war die äh das ist die beste Rolle, die man haben kann, habe ich dann jetzt auch verstanden. Hilfskraftbriefwahl, ja? Hilfskraftbriefwahl ist das, was du möchtest, weil ähm,
Du musst nicht irgendwo um um sieben Uhr im Wahllokal sein, ne? Du hast kein äh Menschenkontakt und Hilfskraft bedeutet eben auch, ne, relativ wenig Verantwortung.
Äh insofern Hilfskraft Briefwahl ist genau das, was man haben möchte, wenn man zumal wenn man's zum ersten Mal macht. Ähm.
Wie war meine Erfahrung? So, da stand drin, sei um 14 Uhr an dieser und jener Schule. Ja gut.
Dann bin ich da äh hingeeilt und war schon so ein bisschen äh ich war also drei, vier Minuten zu spät, ne? Und da habe ich so gedacht, oh scheiße peinlich, ey. Jetzt kommst du da
unpünktlich an, du kommst als letztes. Es ist schon mal irgendwie, machst du schon mal schlechten Eindruck, ne? Und dann komme ich halt an dieser Schule an, deswegen Kreuzberg, Karl von Osjetzki Schule hieß die, ähm
eine relativ große Schule. Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, vom Gebäude her durchaus so wahrscheinlich ein paar tausend Schüler, würde ich ja also, war auf jeden Fall ein großes Schulgebäude, ne.
Oh, er kommt da so an, stehen da irgendwie so äh
Steht da so einer, wo sich so fünf, sechs Leute um den versammeln? Sagst du, ja hallo, ist hier Wahl oder so? Sagt er, ja muss, musstest du zu der und der Schule? Ich sage, ja, sagte, ja, okay, ein ein Schulhof weiter, geh mal dahinten hin, da wirst du das dann schon sehen. Ja gut, dann gehe ich dahin und,
Ist also auf diesem Schulhof stehen so, ich kann jetzt nicht so gut schätzen, aber ich würde mal so sagen, zweihundert Leute, vielleicht auch dreihundert auf diesen Sulo verteilt.
Stehen da so ohne erkennbare.
Ohne erkennbares Ziel, ja? Und ich dachte erst so, na, ob das jetzt Wähler sind oder die haben schon gewählt und jetzt rauchen die noch eine, ne?
Teilweise so Hände in der Tasche und so und dann habe ich so zu allem hin. Ich sage so, hör mal.
Was ist das hier, ne? Wartet ihr auf irgendwas oder.
Ne, weil was ist deine Rolle hier? Ja, nee, ich bin Wahlhelfer. Ich sollte um vierzehn Uhr da sein. Ich sage, ja, okay, ich auch, ne?
Und dann habe ich irgendwie, aber der der war der kam keine Bewegung rein, so passierte nichts, ne. Dann habe ich irgendwann hier von meinem Wal,
Lokal für oder von meinem Wahlbezirk, für den ich da ja eingeteilt war. Also ich hatte quasi eine Vorladung für äh,
eine Einberufung für was weiß ich dieses, also irgendwie fünf A oder was äh in der äh Karl von Osjetzki Schule,
und der Typ hatte mir ja dieser dieser von meinem ursprünglichen Wahldingen da, der hatte ja eine Mail geschrieben,
Von dieser Web DE, E-Mail-Adresse und da habe ich äh hat da hatte deine Handynummer drin und da habe ich da mal angerufen und da habe ich gesagt, hör mal, äh Kollege, ne, ich sollte 41 Uhr da sein, ich bin hier deine Hisskraft. So.
Wie sieht's aus?
Und jetzt pass auf. Also das war jetzt so, da war's jetzt schon so vierzehn Uhr dreißig, würde ich sagen oder vierzehn Uhr fünfundvierzig, ne?
Ja, sagt er, äh ja, also er wäre jetzt äh in dem Raum drin und äh ich sollte mal gucken, ob ich dahin komme.
Ähm allerdings, wer er jetzt auch nicht mehr in der Lage mir zu beschreiben, wo der Raum ist,
Und ähm ich sollte doch am besten mal gucken an dem einen Eingang da steht so eine Frau mit einem Plan.
Und die hätte ihm gesagt, wie er dahin kommt und da soll die eigentlich einfach auch mal hingehen, ja? So,
der Mann hatte Recht, ja? Hinter also so auf einem anderen Teil dieses Schulhofes vor einer anderen Tür stand eine Frau, äh die hatte so.
Ich würde sagen, so fünf, sechs a drei Blätter, die waren oben aneinander getackert und mit denen konnte die,
wo was ist. Die konnte, die hatte quasi so ein Gebäudeplan, ne? Und da konnte die dann, wenn die sagt, dass äh hier ähm.
Da hat man dann angestanden, da war so eine Schlange von, sagen wir mal.
Also die Schlange war immer so zwischen würde ich sagen 40 und und 60 Personen.
Vor dieser Frau.
Vor dieser Frau, ja, aber die wurde ja aber auch relativ zügig abgehandelt, weil jede einzelne Person sagt dir ja nur, was weiß ich
vier V. Äh und dann guckte die Frau auf den Plan, den man natürlich auch hätte aushängen können, ja, wo das ist und sagte dann so, ja, gehst du mal da lang und so, ne? Deswegen, also jede Person, wo du da so, ja, ungefähr dreißig Sekunden behandelt, ja? So,
Habe ich mich in diese Schlange gestellt. Ich hatte übrigens auch hier äh äh Kathrin Röneke noch getroffen, die auch ähnlich erfreut war über die äh über diese Planlosigkeit, die da äh stattfand.
Saßen wir da in. Standen wir da so in der Schlange und dann kam immer wieder mal so Leute
diese an der Schlange vorbeiging und sich nach vorne drängelten, ne? Und dann die anderen protestierten dann natürlich auch und sagten so, ey, Entschuldigung, wir stehen hier alle an und die Leute, die sich da vordrängelten, meinten so, ja, tut mir leid, ich bin Wahlhelfer. Und dann alle so,
Wir auch
ja? Und die diese Leute dachten halt und das so, so blöd, wie da alle standen und planlos, dachten die halt, das dachte ich ja auch, dass dass Wähler sind, ne,
dass die Leute anstehen um zu wählen.
Gemeines Wahlvolk.
So und das waren aber jetzt halt hunderte Wahlhelfer, die nicht wussten, wo sie hin sollten. So, in einer lösbaren Situation, ne? Du hättest nämlich einfach
fucking ausschildern müssen. So, gut, jetzt war ich irgendwann bei dieser Frau dran, ne, die da sehr tapfer ein ineffizienter Prozess, da sind hunderte Menschen, ja. Und die fragen einzeln, ja?
Ähm und da äh sagte ich so, ja hier, ich muss zu fünf haste nicht gesehen und dann sagt sie so, ja okay, dann fingen sie da an zu rascheln, guckte erst so und dann ah okay, das ist in dem und im Gebäudeteil und dann sagte sie, ja, pass auf, also das ist hm.
Ja, pass auf, geh mal am besten da hinten durch die Tür rein, ne und dann gehst du mal in den ersten Stock und dann musst du einfach nochmal gucken,
Das war die Auskunft.
Fast eine halbe Stunde angestanden hast.
Für dich eine halbe Stunde angestanden habe. So, es, es waren am Ende wirklich kein Scheiß. Es war fünfzehn Uhr dreißig, als ich letztendlich in meinem in meinem äh Briefwahlbezirk da angekommen bin.
Hm
Es war dann noch die Situation, dass als ich in dem ursprünglichen, für den ich geladen war, war dann so eine äh junge Frau, die sagte, ja hör mal, ich bin hier mit meiner Freundin, wir wollten das zusammen machen. Die ist hier in diesem anderen Briefwahlbezirk,
ähm wäre das für dich okay zu tauschen,
Ne, dann also äh zählt's halt einen anderen Bezirk aus und wir können das zusammen machen. Da habe ich gesagt, ja, ist doch gar kein Thema. Bin halt einfach nochmal, habe dann quasi nochmal Wahllokal gewechselt, ja? Ähm.
Da war ich um mit mit fünfzehn Uhr dreißig, anderthalb Stunden Verspätung, aber noch einer der ersten.
Da waren. Und du hattest jetzt eine Situation, dass also während ich noch unten stand bei der Frau in der Schlange, ja? Sah ich schon vereinzelt so Leute,
über diesen Schulhof laufen, die hatten so einen die hatten den gesunden DIN A4 Blatt irgendwo gefunden, ja? Und hatten hinten drauf mit Buntstift, so mit hellblauem Buntstift, den sie da in der Schule gefunden hatten. So, was weiß ich.
6G drauf geschrieben, was jetzt ihr Wahlbezirk war und liefen dieses Schild hochhaltend mit suchenden Gesicht über diesen Schulhof, um ihre Hilfskräfte zu finden.
Wie so eine Touristengruppe in Rom irgendwie.
Aber mit so einem ganz weißt du, mit so einem scheiß Buntstiftchen gemalt, so Wachsmaler, so, ne? Und und lief, wie lange? Und du dachtest so, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Es kann einfach nicht wahr sein.
So dann dann muss ich aber sagen, so okay, fünfzehn Uhr dreißig waren wir da. Jetzt hatte ich großes Glück, einen äh Wahlvorstand zu haben.
Äußerst äh kompetent
total fitte Leute. Ähm unsere Wahlvorstände hatte das jetzt, glaube ich, auch schon, die machte da zum vierten Mal, weil jetzt aber erste Mal vorstand, die Wahl enorm gut vorbereitet, ihre Schriftführerin und ihre Beisitzerin auch, das waren so richtig also
super organisierte Leute, die ähm ne, die Prozesse kurz erklärt haben und dann muss ich auch noch dazu sagen, wirklich, alle Leute, die da waren,
ähm fit, intelligente Leute, ja? Nicht irgendwie Handy in der Tasche, sondern die haben alle so gesehen, okay, wie läuft hier der Hase, wie kann ich,
Was kann ich schon mal vorbereiten? Äh hier ich habe gerade nichts zu tun. Ich fange schon mal das an oder so, ne. Ähm wirklich äußerst fit, dieser Auszählvorgang war auch wirklich sehr.
Ähm sehr interessant. Also du musst es ja erstmal, du kriegst ja die roten Umschläge, da drin ist der Wahlschein und dann der blaue Umschlag. So, jetzt gab es aber natürlich Unterscheidung in,
nur Bundestag wählen darf nur Bezirksverordnetenversammlung wählen und so ne also es dürften nicht alle alles wählen wie gesagt wir hatten in Berlin.
Vier Wahlen im Prinzip gleichzeitig.
Genau, mit insgesamt sechs Stimmen, ne? Erst- und Zweitstimme Bundestag, dann BVV und AGH, eine von beiden waren auch nochmal zwei Stimmen.
Und dann bist du bei fünf und dann hattest du noch äh Volksentscheid deutsche Wohnen enteignen. So und jetzt ähm.
Dieser Ausziehprozess ist auch tatsächlich sehr interessant. Ähm.
Und zwar ich mache das jetzt mal nur am Beispiel der Bundestagswahl. Also er, erstmal packst du die, packst du die aus, dann musst du die Wahlscheine äh sammeln und die müssen sortiert werden nach wer darf was wählen, weil daraus ergibt sich ja dann am Ende die Gesamtanzahl der möglichen,
abgegebenen Stimmen, ne?
Halt irgendwie so und so viele Wahlscheine, nur BVV, so und so viele Wahlscheine, alles und so weiter und dann weißt du quasi, okay, so und so viele Stimmen erwarten wir jetzt. Ähm.
Ganz wichtig ist Korrektiv, um am Schluss immer wieder überprüfen zu können, dass man nichts vergessen hat.
Ja oder nicht einer zu viel drin war, ne? Das ist tatsächlich äh na ja und dann äh genau, das das mussten wir erstmal alles auspacken und dann ähm.
Da musst du auch die roten Umschläge beibehalten, weil am Ende musst du natürlich musst du theoretisch in der Lage sein, die Umschläge nachzuzählen, ob du dir auch wirklich alle aufgemacht hast und so. Ähm
oder ob dir da einer, ne, zu viel, das, also es muss alles immer passen. Dann hast du natürlich auch solche Leute, die dann ähm.
Hör mal, wie war da ein Fall, die hatte halt den Wahlschein und den ähm.
Den die äh die hatte quasi offenbar ihren Wahlschein da reingelegt, hatte den blauen Umschlag schon zu und hatte aber jetzt hier die den Volksentscheid vergessen und hat den aber dann noch offen mit in den Umschlag getan,
ne? Und da war dann jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Fall, da das sind dann so Beschlusssachen, da muss dann der Wahlvorstand eben gemeinsam nach Regularien entscheiden, was machst du jetzt mit dieser Stimme, ne? Ist jetzt nur diese Volksentscheidstimme ungültig,
oder ist der gesamte Umschlag ungültig, ne.
Weil das Problem ist, mit diesen diese, da hat sie jetzt quasi ihre geheim die geheime Wahl ja verwirkt, ne, weil sie den.
Zu dem Wahlzettel gelegt hat und du weißt ja nicht, ob in dem ähm Umschlag nicht nochmal so ein Ding drin ist, ne? Und dann hättest du auf einmal mehr gehabt,
Und da musst du sowas entscheiden. Dafür gibt's dann quasi auch Anleitungen, ne? Aber da da lag halt dann auch, da es gab,
also auf dem Tisch, in diesem Wahllokal, was wir da äh betrieben haben, ne, was ja eigentlich so ein Klassenzimmer war, lagen halt noch mal so, last minute Korrekturen zum,
Wahlerlass. So irgendwie so, übrigens, sorry, da steht auf Seite so und so, wenn irgendwas offen drin liegt, müsst ihr so und so werten,
Ist aber falsch. Ihr müsst so und so werten, also ging's glaube ich um die Frage, ähm ist in einem solchen Fall alles ungültig oder nur der Teil, der nicht im Umschlag lag,
Und da gab's dann noch so Last-Minute-Korrekturen zu den zu den quasi Anweisungen, wie du auszuzählen hast. Also es ist Katastrophe. Na ja.
Unser Team total fit. Wir hatten diese äh Umschlagssituation geklärt bis, ich glaube, sechzehn Uhr fünfundvierzig, ne. Es war etwas unter einer Stunde. Wir konnten nochmal nach Hause gehen äh bis achtzehn Uhr.
Mussten dann wieder da sein zum Auszählen und dann durften wir erstmal nicht auszählen, weil,
Wir mussten warten, weil es hätte ja sein können, dass jetzt nochmal irgendwie so nochmal Stimmen kommen,
die die jetzt noch irgendwo zentral eingegangen sind bei der Post am Samstagabend und dann irgendwie noch hierhin geliefert würden oder sowas, da mussten wir noch warten bis 18 Uhr noch was, bis wir anfangen durften.
Und äh achtzehn Uhr dreißig oder achtzehn Uhr fünfundvierzig durften wir dann anfangen. Da machst du halt die ganzen Dinge auf und sortierst du die Wahlzettel. Und dann gibt's halt zum Beispiel das erste, was du machst, ist, du nimmst die ganzen Bundestagswahl Stimmen und sortierst die in,
Erst- und Zweitstimme gleich oder ungleich.
Ja. Genauso war das bei uns auch. Mhm.
Naja, also da gehe ich davon aus, das wird bei dir genauso, also das wird einheitlich so gewesen sein, ne, dann sortierst die nach gleich oder ungleich. Und dann.
Oder nach Leer und nach äh zu klären, ne? Das waren so diese vier Stapel, auf die das erstmal mhm.
Und dann ähm.
Quasi diese vorstehende ruft dann immer quasi den Parteinamen aus und jeder jede von uns hatte so sagen wir was weiß ich drei, vier Parteien.
Für die du dann verantwortlich warst, ne? Dann sagt dir so Grüne und dann hier zack und dann nimmt die das, nimmt diese andere Person das entgegen, die quasi für das Zählen der grünen Stimmen verantwortlich ist, ne?
Gab's natürlich auch so ein paar Arschkarten Parteien, ne, so AFD und so, ja, das war dann immer, äh, die wollte keiner, aber einer hat dann, der einer hat sich dann geopfert, immer die AfD zu zählen. Das war zum Glück immer relativ wenig, ja? Äh, insofern hat das auch Vorteile, ne?
Und äh genau, dann.
Aber interessantes Konzept, das wurde zum Beispiel bei uns äh nicht so äh mit Ausrufen nicht so gemacht. Wir.
Das ist aber das ist tatsächlich also dieses Verfahren muss man schon sagen, das hat das macht so durchaus Sinn.
Das mit dem Ausrufen, weil du da halt eine doppelte Korrektur drin hast, ne, dass dass man einmal das sagt und dann nimmst der andere entgegen und das ist auch, das ist der Weg, wie es zu sein hat, ja? Und das macht auch Sinn.
Ja, ich habe dann immer äh paar spitze Kommentare gegeben, die sollen nochmal irgendwie die Zettel.
So durchzählen, dass man irgendwie auch alle äh alle Felder sehen kann, wenn sie da irgendwie Entscheidungen fällen. Ähm so beim Beobachten, ne? Ähm das ging mir dann teilweise auch zu hektisch. Ich meine, ist natürlich auch problematisch,
ihr wart jetzt in einer besseren Situation, dadurch, dass ihr erst so spät angefangen habt, ne, aber in dem.
Nicht irgendeinen laseweisen Kommentator noch dabeihalten.
Sogar noch einen anderen, der alles aufgeschrieben hat. Ähm nee, ich glaube, ich war eher das geringere Problem. Ich wollte da ja auch eher ähm konstruktiv äh das Ganze begleiten. Nee, aber teilweise waren die Leute halt seit sieben Uhr vor Ort.
Ja, haben da äh die ganze Zeit diese Leute und kannst du dir vorstellen, wenn da,
sozusagen dein ganzes Volk da äh durchrauscht, dann ist da mal wieder irgendwas und dann Corona und Maske und hast nicht gesehen und desinfizieren und irgendwie nur so und so viele Leute rein. Zu wenig Wahlkabinen,
Dann diese anstehenden Problematik und dann halt irgendwann, oh jetzt fehlen die Wahlzettel.
Der eine ist ja dann sozusagen noch losgefahren zum Bezirksamt, weil die ja selber nichts gebracht haben,
Ja, sie haben sich zwar schon frühzeitig beschwert und gesagt, ja hier Wahlzettel, das wird nicht ausreichen, wir haben einfach nicht genug was was was erlaube kam natürlich irgendwie nix, selber noch ins Auto gesetzt, hingefahren.
Und äh angestanden, wo ganz viele Leute rumstanden an diesem Bezirksamt und alle irgendwie am Schreien waren und wir brauchen hier irgendwie Wahlzettel
dann kam irgendwie noch die Polizei vorbei, die äh auch von irgendjemand beauftragt wurde, jetzt mal hier irgendwo Wahlzettel vorbeizubringen
fühlte sich ganz wichtig, wolltest du dich da nur wie vordringen, sondern wir sind hier die Polizei, wir müssen irgendwie Wahlzettel holen, wir wollen hier alle Wahlzettel haben, stellt euch gefälligst hin
Mann. Ja, so, ne? Und in diesem ganzen Stress und dann ist achtzehn Uhr, dann stehst du irgendwie da schon elf Stunden und dann nochmal
warten, weil die Schlange noch abgearbeitet werden muss. Dann geht's um neunzehn Uhr dreißig irgendwie erst so richtig los und dann musst du irgendwie vier Wahlen auszählen und dann noch die Konzentration hochhalten. Das war natürlich schwierig, weil dann mal irgendwie alle nach Hause ja,
manche krank, bla, bla, bla.
Also da ist eine gute Bruce, du absolut wichtig. Ist sehr wichtig, dass diese Wahlvorstände das gut äh durchziehen. Bei dir schien's noch ein bisschen,
stringenter durchgezogen worden zu sein, alles in allem fand ich's jetzt nicht bedrohlich schlecht. Also es war okay.
Also ich muss sagen, die äh also der vielleicht ganz kurz noch
Also wie wird dann weiter ausgezählt? Du hast dann quasi jetzt die gleichen Stimmen, ne? Dann fängst du an, die Zweitstimmen auszuzählen. Das heißt, du nimmst den, du nimmst den Stapel mit den ungleichen Stimmen, ne?
Und du gehst in einmal durch nach der Zweitstimme und dann nimmst du den gleichen Stapel nochmal und gehst den durch nach der Erststimme, ne? Nach diesem Verfahren. Und ähm.
So spielst du dieses Spiel, dann werden immer die Zahlen mit aufgeschrieben und dann guckt die Schriftführerin, ne, ob sie ob die Summen stimmen, ja, also,
deckt sich das, ne, die Summe gültiger, ungültiger und sonst was abgegebener Stimmen.
Deckt die sich mit der Anzahl der Wahlzettel. Wenn nicht, dann muss er herausfinden wieso und das kann natürlich schiefgehen. Und deswegen nochmal, also unser Team war wirklich
würde sagen herausragend und wir waren gegen zweiundzwanzig Uhr fertig mit den ganzen Schnatterer Denken und da habe ich noch als wir quasi schon unsere also als wir da uns darüber Gedanken gemacht haben einzupacken.
Habe ich dann noch einen Kumpel aufm Flur getroffen und sagte so, ja, wir sind fertig und er so, ja, wir sind jetzt auch mit dem Bundestag fertig, ne. Also die hatten die Bundestagswahl in der gleichen Zeit ausgezählt, wie wir die gesamte Wahl.
Briefe, ja. Gleiche Bedingungen, die hatten halt, äh, ehrlich gesagt, wieso habt ihr denn so lange gebraucht? Seid ihr immer irgendwie eine Inkonsistenz, dann musste das nochmal zählen. Also, da muss man wirklich sagen, da richtig penibele,
Leute zu haben ist halt,
unabdingbar und ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, wenn du da nicht gut vorbereitet bist, wie dir sowas äh schief gehen kann. Jetzt hast du gerade schon gesagt, ähm.
Ein Freund von uns äh,
Erdgeist, der ist macht das ja auch so, der ist ja schon so Wahlhelfer, veteran. Der macht das, ich weiß nicht, schon schon immer und äh der war jetzt irgendwie in so einem Wahllokal dann hier auch Wahlvorstände und so, ne? Und der sagte halt auch, sechs, sechs Uhr fünfundvierzig da sein.
Wahllokal aufbauen, damit das um 8 Uhr öffnen kann und er hat da halt auch schon gesehen, da viel zu wenig Wahlkabinen konnte sich quasi an der Größe des Wahlbezirks schon wusste der quasi schon um um 7 Uhr, dass das.
Dieses Wahllokal, was sie da jetzt,
nicht in der Lage sein würde, diese Menschen abzufertigen. Erst dann auch noch irgendwie selber mit dem Roller in der Pause Wahlzettel äh holen gefahren. Und also wirklich, da muss man einfach sagen, diese ganze
Wurde gerettet von den Wahlhelferinnen
ne? Und als wir dann als wir dann da fertig waren, ne, also den Teil, den wir gemacht haben, wirklich dankt unserer Dank unserer bevorstehenden, großartig. Und dann sagen wir.
Jo, hi, wir sind jetzt, wir sind fertig, ne? Wir sind durch. Äh, ja.
Runterfahren da gibt's auch ein Fahrstuhl. Ah ja super, wo ist denn der Fasching? Du, das weiß ich nicht.
So, okay, komm, wir tragen das Scheißchen. Die Urne war übrigens eine Mülltonne, ne? Äh was, also die passte von der Größe her, ne, war war halt eine Mülltonne.
Ja, passt doch auch irgendwie zu Berlin so ein bisschen. Mhm.
Ähm und äh naja, dann habe ich mir noch angeschaut, das war natürlich der andere Teil, der mich interessiert hat, wie passieren denn die Schnellmeldungen? Ja, in dieser Schule wurden ja, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Wahlbezirke ausgezählt.
Da Briefwahlbezirke und ähm.
Die Schnellmeldungen waren halt äh da saßen unten im im Erdgeschoss, gab's so, boah verwandert, neun oder zwölf.
So so Tische, an denen jeweils eine Person mit einem Computer saß und die tippten dann,
Schnellmeldungsergebnisse ein, ne? Und da da ging dann quasi die Schriftführerin oder eine äh bevollmächtigte Hilfskraft runter und sagte, aha, okay, ah ja, was was äh
tippt ihr jetzt hier ein. Ja, wir haben jetzt hier, ne, Wahlbezirk a sechs a, haste nicht gesehen,
Mhm, okay, dann sag mal, und dann wurden halt die Stimmen durchgetippt in so ein in so eine Weboberfläche und dann äh war der, war das, war das Ding fertig.
Ach echt, ne, mit der Weppoberfläche wurde das gemacht.
Ja, das war äh und zwar.
Bei uns war das telefonisch.
Ja, dass also dann hat's wahrscheinlich da dann jemand äh digital eingetippt.
Auch kein Netz. Es gab auch kein Netz in diesem äh Kindergarten.
Also du machst halt, also das war ja hier auch so, ne, da so relativ offensichtlich gab es da jetzt ein paar Leute, die zu diesem eintippen befähigt waren.
Bevollmächtigt waren, aber eben noch sehr viel mehr, die denen halt ihre Zahlen gesagt haben. Wahrscheinlich hättest du die auch anrufen können, aber entscheidend ist eben, irgendwann muss ja irgendjemand diese Sachen eintippen, ne. Und das haben sie offenbar nicht runterskaliert, bis auf das auf das Einzelne,
Wahlbüro, sondern eben auf einer etwas höheren Ebene dann äh angedingst. Deswegen wundert mich nicht, dass ihr jetzt da mit einem mit einem Wahllokal,
halt eine telefonische Meldung macht, aber die Person, mit der jeder telefoniert hat, die wird das dann eben in diese Weboberfläche eingetippt haben.
Diese Schnellmeldung ist nur für den Bundestag, muss man mal dazu sagen, nur für die Bundestagswahl.
Ja auf jeden Fall dafür ist sie entscheidend, ne. In in Charlottenburg-Wilmersdorf haben sie ja so verkackt, dass sie die Schnellmeldungen geschätzt haben.
Geschätzte Wahl, die aber geschätzt.
Das ist aber jetzt das vorläufige Ergebnis, ne? Ja, die müssen dann, die chillen die dann jetzt nochmal in Ruhe aus und dann äh werden sie das korrigieren. Werden sie sehen, ob ihre Schätzungen richtig war.
Also dass diese Landeswahlleiterin von Berlin ja noch einen Tag gebraucht hat, bis sie irgendwie zurück zum Rücktritt äh
gegangen ist. Das hat mich schon äh wirklich beeindruckt so. Also sie haben auch wirklich am Anfang noch versucht, sich da groß rauszureden und es wird auch alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Aber dann wurde der Druck dann doch relativ schnell, weil diesmal ist für dich so dermaßen viel daneben gegangen. Ich meine, es sind Leute, teilweise abgewiesen worden, ja, wir haben hier keine Wahlzettel
ja, die Leute wollten einfach nicht länger in der Schlange stehen. Da stehen dann alte Leute, die einfach mit dem Stehen an sich schon mal Probleme haben. Du kannst da irgendwie so Achtzigjährige nicht irgendwie zwei Stunden in so einer Schlange stehen lassen, ja. Gut, die wundern teilweise auch vorgelassen, aber
Es sind auch viele Leute abgedreht. Dann gab's halt sowas wie ja äh wir haben jetzt hier also Erststimme haben wir, haben wir nicht,
So, aber die anderen kannst du alle wählen, könnt ihr jetzt warten, bis der da ist oder ihr wählt jetzt so und dann haben halt manche Leute gesagt, so keine Zeit mehr irgendwie, bis ich,
Billig jetzt lieber so viel wie ich wie wie ich kann. Das ist einfach also das ist einfach.
Ja, das ist, also es ist äh tatsächlich eine,
Also es ist eine Katastrophe und jetzt können wir auch mal, gut, jetzt haben wir es einmal ein bisschen erzählt, weil Tim zum ersten Mal äh in Deutschland in der Bundestagswahl teilnehmen durfte, weil ich.
Und einer Landtagswahl.
Und äh ich zum ersten Mal Wahlhelfer war und wir jetzt beide Mal äh so eine Führung in der Wurstfabrik gemacht haben, aber.
Ja.
Ähm und ähm warum diskutieren wir das hier in Lokbuch Netzpolitik nochmal so ausführlich? Weil was jetzt passieren wird, ist.
Dass diese Vorkommnisse natürlich genutzt werden, die nächsten Wochen, Jahr, Monate und Jahre von der Lobby
für äh digitale Wahlsysteme, ne? Die werden sagen, ey schaut euch das an, was da in Berlin los war. Äh das lag an an Stift und Papier, ja? Und wenn wir das jetzt schön digital gemacht hätten.
Dann hätten wir eine.
Werden das nicht nur sagen, die sagen das auch schon.
Genau. Und jetzt ist halt der Punkt, den muss man sich, glaube ich, klar machen, diese ganze Angelegenheit.
Konnte gerettet werden.
Und wurde gerettet, weil es mit den vielen tausend Wahlhelferinnen in Deutschland ähm oder in Berlin.
Kompetente Menschen gab, die diesen Prozess verstanden haben und retten konnten. Ja, also.
Ding, diese Wahl wurde gerettet von Leuten wie, wir haben ihn ja erwähnt, den Erdgeist und bei dir ist er auch Freundinnen und Freunde in dem in dem äh Wahllokal
hoffen und eben auch jetzt in in meinem kleinen Teil, ne, die die äh drei Frauen, die bei uns den Vorstand gemacht haben und die waren jetzt so fünf, sechs andere Leute, die da als Hilfskräfte wirklich eine mitgedacht haben und
gut gearbeitet haben, das sind die Menschen, die diesen Wahlprozess gerettet haben, weil sie ihn verstanden haben und ihn retten konnten,
Und wenn du das jetzt digital machst, dann hast du das auf einmal nicht mehr. Und dieser Wahlprozess ist doch ziemlich kompliziert. Ja? Und den wenn du jetzt sagst, okay,
also wenn das jetzt ein Digitalding wäre, dann wird das nicht einfacher
So, es wird, es wird nicht besser dadurch, dass du jetzt, dass du einen Prozess machst, den auf einmal nicht mehr, wenn irgendwo was klemmt, eine, ein Wahlhelfer, äh, ein ehrenamtlicher Wahlhelfer, äh, oder 'ne Wahlvorstehende, kurz mal eben.
Im Sinne der Lösung zielorientiert fixen kann,
oder ob du halt auf einmal da stehst und sagst, der Drucker funktioniert nicht, ne? Und deswegen, denke ich, ist ist die Leere, die man daraus ziehen muss, ganz klar ähm,
dass man eben nicht dieses Verfahren jetzt auch noch digitalisieren möchte. Na, weil das wäre halt wirklich dann, dass der der Richtige der richtige Untergang
Ja, dass, dass, das ist, glaube ich, der wirklich der genau falsche Schluss und der wird jetzt äh propagiert werden. Das finde ich sehr äh ja, sehr, sehr besorgniserregend, ehrlich gesagt.
Also auch die Debatte muss man sich auf jeden Fall einstellen. Die kommt ja immer wieder und dann gibt's halt so
ich sage mal so, äh diese Modernisierung, ja, wir müssen ja modern sein oder mit der Zeit
gehen und es kann ja nicht sein, dass und hätte man das mit dem Internet gemacht und so weiter und dann irgendwie dieser Mythos Wahlbeteiligung
alles totaler Unsinn, ne. Also man kann es einfach nicht oft genug wiederholen, dass einfach
eine digitale Wahl, nicht nur diese ganzen Sicherheitsfaktoren ausschaltet, die wir
benannt haben, also so diese ganzen ja, die es gibt, einfach dadurch, dass Leute, dass du aktiv ähm machen können, aber halt auch die grundsätzlichen Argumente.
Nicht überprüfbar, nicht nachzählbar, et cetera, also auch generell verstößt es eben auch gegen unsere Gesetzgebung und und die Verfassung
Das ist ja auch vom Verfassungsgericht schon mal festgestellt worden im Rahmen dieser ganzen Wahlcomputerauseinandersetzung vor zehn Jahren. Aber es ist halt auch,
Illusion zu glauben, dass die Komplexität einfacher werden würde,
wenn man jetzt hier irgendwie Computer aufstellt, ich meine wenn man muss sich ja nur mal anschauen was die Verwaltung für Probleme hat überhaupt irgendwie Computer für den normalen Tagesbetrieb irgendwie,
Griff zu behalten. Und dann haben wir hier nun so und so oft über äh besprochen. Ja, was ist, wenn jetzt irgendwie alle Wahlergebnisse erstmal mit mit 3tausend Bitcoin freigekauft werden müssen? Wollen wir das? Also nee
und äh von daher bitte vergessen, diese ganzen Sachen. Und wer auch immer mit so einem äh Unsinn äh aufkommt, soll irgendwie LNP hören.
Es gibt einen äh noch mal einen ausführlicheren Bericht von Christian Waldhoff beim Verfassungsblock, äh der äh dann auch so das Fazit zieht, so,
Also.
Es wäre jetzt eigentlich gut, äh wenn es jetzt hier mal eine also wenn hier jetzt mal die Rechtsschutzmöglichkeiten ausgeschöpft würden.
Ähm und diese Wahl dann eben auch mal kritisiert wird, nicht weil er das in Frage stellen möchte, weil es auch wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
relevant ist, die Wahlfehler, die aufgetreten sind, aber das halt eine Feststellung der Rechts und zugleich der Verfassungswidrigkeit der Vorkommnisse wegen gravierenden Organisationsverschulden der Landeswahlleitung
durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht um den Verfassungsgerichtshof von Berlin äh festgestellt würde, weil das eben politischen und rechtlichen Wert hätte,
ja? Ähm der eben auch sagt so, dass das also das muss Konsequenzen haben auch rechtlicher Art, damit
auch das Vertrauen in diesen Wahlprozess wieder äh hergestellt wird und die äh natürlich kann er das noch sehr viel besser verargumentieren, als wir das jetzt hier kurz mal mit einem kleinen Zitat aus seinem Text tun.
Ich glaube, es war auch der Artikel, als der rauskam. Da war's dann irgendwie vorbei mit der Landeswahlleiterin in Berlin. Also da.
Ich habe ja auch schon gesagt, die müssen ja die die Wahl muss ja sowieso annulliert werden, Tim, ne? Weißt wieso? Ich habe dann am Montag im Briefkasten gehabt, meinen Schnelltest. Also am, am Montag nach der Wahl.
Ach so, den sie dir zugeschickt haben für die Wahlauszählung.
Ja, das ist ja, den den ich hätte, den hätte ich machen müssen, aber ich bin da quasi ungetestet.
Tut mir leid, also.
Ja, gibt auch noch so ein paar andere Aspekte äh der Wahl, äh wo ich ganz froh wäre, wenn die nochmal wiederholt werden würde, aber davon unabhängig ist es einfach auch so, es ist so viel.
Falsch gelaufen, auf so vielen Ebenen. Es war nicht eine Sache, sondern es war halt Wahlzettel nicht verfügbar, falsche Wahlzettel, allgemein schlechte Organisationen, Vorbereitungen
ähm und auch ein totaler äh Unfähigkeit äh kurzfristig auf diese Situation zu reagieren, ja?
Und das ist alles ähm.
Schwer vorstellbar. Ne, jetzt ist äh glaube ich die Position der Landeswahlleiterin, wenn ich das richtig sehe, war sogar eine ehrenamtliche Tätigkeit. Da frage ich mich ja wirklich, ähm wie das äh sein kann.
Also das ist ähm.
Ja, das ist ohne also ich meine das ehrlich gesagt ist mir unerheblich, ob das ehrenamtlich ist oder nicht, entscheidend ist, dass es dass es ordentlich läuft. Aber ich denke, das haben wir jetzt auch äh.
Ausführlich diskutiert.
Ausführlich erört hat. Das ist äh diese Prozesse sind simpel genug, dass man sie hinkriegen kann
Und ich denke, das ist hier die die entscheidende Botschaft und sie waren glücklicherweise simpel genug, dass sie dann eben von den vielen ehrenamtlichen Wahlhelferinnen gerettet werden konnten,
auf viele konventionelle und unkonventionelle Wege und das ist genau auch wiederum die Stärke dieses Prozesses.
Genau, also ihr solltet euch auch mal melden. Ich kann das empfehlen. Ähm das äh ist auf jeden Fall interessant und äh gut, vielleicht ist man da etwas überlastet mal den Tag über, aber was müsst ihr denn sonst mit eurem Sonntag anzufangen, mal ehrlich?
Also ich würd's, ich muss sagen, hm, also ich würd's gerne wieder machen, ich hätte ein bisschen Sorge, nicht Hilfskraft äh Briefwahl zu sein, weil das war echt halt ein geiler Job so,
morgens um sieben ein Wahllokal aufbauen muss und dann da die ganzen Vögel reinkommen da weiß ich nicht, ob ich den Job so geil fände, da habe ich noch sehr viel mehr Respekt vor vor den Leuten, die das gemacht haben,
dann auch irgendwie ach so, genau das, das habe ich eine schöne Geschichte. Es gibt ja dann, also es gab die Frage, wie gehst du halt mit Maskenverweigerern um, ja?
Da gab's ja dann auch hier so einige, also in einer Situation, da hat haben sie dann ihr einen ohne Maske nicht reingelassen. Und das ist natürlich das, was woraus diese Querdenker dann da,
ähm äh anliegen, ja?
Dass sie dann nämlich sagen können, hier sie dürfen nur mit Maulkorb wählen, ne? Und dann haben sie aber auch schon ihr Handy in der Tasche, um da irgendeinen Instagram-Story draus zu machen oder so, ne.
Und da hat eine äh Wahlhelferin mir erzählt, ähm die,
quasi dann auch so einen Vogel hatten und die hatten sich vorher schon entschieden, haben gesagt, pass auf, wenn hier jemand ohne Maske reinkommt und sich weigert, die anzuziehen, gar kein Problem, dann lassen wir den einfach draußen warten, bis das ganze Wahllokal leer ist
ja? Und dann kann diese Person, lass mal einfach alleine durchgehen. Wir sind ja alle geimpft
dann setzen wir uns unsere Maske auf, fertigen diese Person ab und dann wenn die wieder raus ist, können wieder alle anderen rein, ja? Und haben sich dann quasi äh,
entschieden, diese Person wählen zu lassen.
Und äh ihr jeden Wind aus den Segeln zu nehmen, ja? Und dann ist da halt irgendwie so ein Vogel reingekommen, der natürlich dann da,
sprechen ein riesiges Drama veranstaltet hat und die hier jetzt müsste alles desinfizieren, Maulkorb und die haben sich halt überhaupt nicht davon beeindrucken lassen. Haben denen dann gesagt, ja, zeigen sie mal bitte ihren Ausweis, dann hat er einen Ausweis gegeben, er so, können sie bitte die Sonnenbrille abnehmen, ne,
Sonnenbrille abgenommen in äh irgendwie diesen Typen halt einfach völlig auflaufen lassen, weil der natürlich jetzt das große Drama,
spielen wollte und die haben ihm halt einfach allen Wind aus den Segeln genommen, indem sie den Typen einfach am wehlen lassen und ähm
so einen schönen Abschluss.
Und zwar der Wahlzettel musste quasi zweimal gefaltet werden, damit er durch den Schlitz passt, ja? Und dann kam dieser Typ halt mit einem einmal gefalteten Wahlzettel da raus,
und dann haben sie ihm gesagt, sie müssen die Nummer falten. Ich lasse mir von euch nicht sagen, wie ich den Zell zu falten habe. Ging daher zur Urne
hat dann festgestellt, dass er den da nicht reinkriegt, ne, weil der Schlitz halt nicht groß genug.
Hatte dann nochmal gefaltet und ist dann irgendwie äh hustend und spuckend irgendwie dramatisch äh da raus gegangen und ja, dass die Tochter hat auch ganz schöne.
Ganz schöne Erfahrung. Aber ja, also ich würd's wieder machen, aber so ein bisschen ich glaube,
so wie das jetzt für mich, wenn ich jetzt erzählen kann, dass es insgesamt recht locker war, lag äh wie gesagt war ein Glückstreffer von Briefwahl und,
Team, das hat andere äh sehr viel härter erwischt, die dann da wirklich,
Erdgeist zum Beispiel, ne, von sechs Uhr fünfundvierzig bis irgendwie zweiundzwanzig, dreiundzwanzig Uhr auf den Beinen waren, das ist dann schon eine sehr viel härtere Nummer.
Kommen wir zur eigentlichen Wahl, also zur Bundestagswahl. Berlin müssen wir, glaube ich, nicht äh groß drüber sprechen.
Ja, also Ergebnis ist ja ganz klar, äh die CDU hat einen klaren Regierungsauftrag bekommen von ihren Wählern.
Arme Laschet, ja. Festgestellt.
Ich denke da, also da wurde jetzt lange genug drüber diskutiert, was hier jetzt gerade die Situation ist. So. Wir haben,
die SPD hat mehr Stimmen bekommen als die CDU und zwar signifikant mehr, dass,
irgendwas fast zwei Prozent, das äh kommt auf irgendwie fast eine Millionen Stimmen. Also es ist relativ eindeutig, dass die CDU eine historische und verdiente äh Wahlschlappe eingefahren hat.
Und die wahrscheinlichsten Koalitionsvarianten äh sind gerade mit der grünen Partei.
Und der FDP ähm sehr zu meiner Überraschung ist.
Die Option einer Jamaika-Koalition, also schwarz, grün, gelb ähm noch nicht vom Tisch.
Was sich äh durchaus ähm.
Bedenklich findet, dass man über so etwas überhaupt noch nachdenken kann in dieser Rolle, aber das ist natürlich dann der FDP zu verdanken. Ähm und,
Ja, es ist so, wenn jetzt hier irgendwas mit Anstand gemacht wird, dann wird das im Zweifelsfall eine rot-grün-gelbe äh Koalition,
oder halt 'ne GroKo unter Söder, ne? Das ist also ich mein das wär so die andere, die andere Alternative. Ich kann nur sagen, wenn, also wenn die Grünen jetzt.
In dieser Situation äh der CDU zur Regierung verhelfen.
Können sie einpacken.
Können die einpacken. So, da können die, da braucht man gar nicht weiter drüber zu reden, ne. Dann können die einpacken
Und äh da bin ich jetzt mal äh,
wie sich wie lange das dauern wird, bis sie das dann auch mal in aller Schärfe sagen. Die SPD äh tritt ja die FDP tritt ja jetzt hier mit äh stolz geschwellter Brust auf und sind eigentlich der kleinste.
Kleinste äh Stimmchen in diesem drei, in dieser äh Bande, aber äh haben natürlich irgendwie immer sehr viel, sehr viel Selbstbewusstsein. Ich denke.
Ähm für die netzpolitische Ausrichtung der nächsten vier Jahre.
Ist es auf jeden Fall kein so schlechtes Zeichen, wenn die Grünen und die FDP äh hier dann,
hoffentlich eine äh Rolle spielen werden, weil natürlich die FDP größtenteils ähm
sehr gute netzpolitische Positionen hat und äh die Grünen auch größtenteils sehr gute netzpolitische Position haben. Da gibt's immer mal äh,
der ein oder anderen Sachfrage vielleicht Abweichungen im Detail, aber grundsätzlich ist das haben die sag ich mal sehr viel bessere Position als
CDU äh und SPD.
In den letzten Jahren äh gemeinsam oder getrennt voneinander hinbekommen haben. Das heißt, politisch
rein netzpolitisch sieht das gerade erstmal noch ganz positiv aus. Ja wenn die FDP in in den Traditionen zum Beispiel von jemand wie Frau Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger oder Gerhard Baum
weiterarbeiten möchte.
Ja, also teile ich die,
deine Ansicht und äh ich wäre auch sehr überrascht, wenn es äh nicht zu einer Ampel kommt. Ich denke, alles andere, also eine Koalition unter Teilnahme der CDU lässt sich einfach überhaupt nicht vertreten. Also man muss sich ja auch nur anschauen
welche Auflösungserscheinung die CDU jetzt seit der Wahl auch schon übergegangen ist, also die darf,
Die hat jetzt sagen wir mal so das Glück, was die SPD auch schon mal hatte, dass sie sich mal so komplett neu erfinden darf. Und das äh.
Auch was Gutes haben, auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt damit rechne, dass sie sich natürlich mittelfristig dann etwas rechter äh positionieren werden, ganz klar, ne, so aus der Opposition heraus, da kann man dann mal wieder alles fordern. Ähm das ist dann potentiell, glaube ich, auch eher ein Problem für die AfD.
Ähm.
Auf dem linken Spektrum muss er auch die linke äh extrem einstecken und ist nur deshalb wieder in der im Bundestag gelandet, weil's ihn mit Acht gelungen ist, drei,
Wahlbezirke zu gewinnen, direkt, wenn auch nicht unbedingt die drei, die eigentlich bisher immer als sicher galten in Berlin, da waren's dann nur zwei und weil sie Leipzig noch gewonnen haben, hat's dann gereicht.
Insofern ähm hätten wir natürlich mit einer Ampel auch so eine klassische Mitterregierung,
ähm die sowohl eine rechte als auch eine linke Opposition hat, wenngleich eben die rechte Opposition natürlich sehr viel stärker äh ist als die Linke,
muss man sehen ähm zumindest ist die Opposition auch stark und das wird dann eben auch die äh politische Auseinandersetzung prägen. Was nicht so schön ist, ist, dass natürlich die ganze Wahlrechtsreform
äh der letzten Jahre äh misslungen ist, die ja eigentlich vom Verfassungsgericht angemahnt wurde und jetzt kommen ja noch mehr Leute im Bundestag sitzen.
Was dazu führte, dass die Verluste bei ähm Union und AFD sich auch nicht so ganz äh stark durchgeschlagen haben, wie sie's vielleicht hätten können, trotz alledem haben die beide weniger Sitze bekommen.
Alle anderen haben mehr, ach so außer die äh Linken natürlich, die hatten haben auch äh stark verloren, die sind jetzt nur noch mit neununddreißig äh vertreten und das war vorher waren's neunundsechzig, also da gehen dreißig Leute raus. Das ist natürlich hart
Ähm.
Ein paar uns äh äh vertrautere Personen der Linken, die wir hier auch schon in der Sendung äh hatten. Martina Renner ist, glaube ich, noch dabei, ne? Und Anke, Dom Schaltbergs, glaube ich, auch dabei, richtig.
Ja
Mhm. Insofern nochmal ganz gut. Und der Süd schließliche Schleswiger Villa Verband,
stellt auch eine ein Sitz diesmal interessanterweise.
Ja, wir also schauen wir uns mal an, wie das jetzt da äh läuft mit den äh mit den.
Koalitionsverhandlungen und ja, die Linke wird sich jetzt,
ähm endlich äh mal reformieren müssen, immerhin ist ja jetzt äh so ein bisschen klar, dass äh Lafontaine und Wagenknecht äh bereit sind.
Da jetzt mal das Ruder aus der Hand zu geben und äh da denke ich,
hoffe ich, dass die Partei sich da jetzt äh endgültig mal äh besinnt, ja und eben der äh.
Der der Teil der Partei, die wirklich politisch sind, ähm.
Sich dann eben auch durchsetzt und da vernünftig formieren kann. Wenn dreißig Leute gehen, das ist natürlich, da macht er auch
ähm Anne Roth nochmal drauf aufmerksam, dann gehen ja nochmal von denen gehen ja auch nochmal die Mitarbeiter, ne? Das heißt, das sind äh kannst du nochmal sagen, das sind äh am Ende 90 oder 120 gute Leute, je nachdem wie viele Mitarbeiter
dann jeweils dann noch mit noch mitzählst, die eben auch die ganze Arbeit machen, ne.
Aber man muss natürlich auch sehen, die Zeit, wo die Linke noch aus ihrer alten, aus ihrem Volksparteistatus äh im Osten zehren konnte, die sind jetzt weitgehend vorbei. Ja, also bis auf diese.
Nee, im Osten ist das äh haben die schon noch äh davon zehren können, dass ungefähr das einzige, von denen sie noch zehren konnten, ne.
Ja, ja gut, aber es ist halt einfach, dass die Leute, die jetzt so Linke gewählt haben, wegen Osten und wegen Protest,
Ja, die äh sind dann auch jetzt äh bei der AfD angekommen.
Und das nicht zu knapp. Und ich meine, wenn man sich äh die Wahlergebnisse in Sachsen anschaut, da kann einem schon schwummrig werden, ne. Ich meine, Sachsen, äh da haben sie halt einfach alle.
Bis auf einen ähm, glaube ich, Wahlbezirk gewonnen
direkt die Direktkandidaten, was aber das auch diesen lustigen Effekt hatte. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast, dass damit die ganze Liste nicht mehr aktiv wurde. Also dadurch, dass in Sachsen so viele
Leute direkt gewählt wurden, kam niemand mehr von der Liste runter und alle Leute, die irgendwie letztes Jahr für Sachsen im Bundestag waren, sind jetzt nicht mehr im Bundestag,
weil die halt keinen kein Direktmandat äh angestrebt haben, sondern eben nur über die Liste abgesichert waren, aber dadurch, dass das halt über die äh Direktmandate schon abgefrühstückt wurde im Verhältnis zu ihren Zweitstimmen
wurde die Liste gar nicht mehr aktiviert. Also da sind dann auch so ein paar äh rechtslastige äh ähm gleiche rausgefallen, aber es ist natürlich immer noch zu viele.
Also wirklich wirr äh die erste Wahl übrigens in Deutschland, glaube ich, seit 49 wohnen, keine Partei mehr als 30 Prozent bekommen hat. Also diese Zersiedlung und Fraktionisierung,
ist stark. Es muss nicht unbedingt schlecht sein, aber zumindest ist so diese Zeit der Volksparteien ein bisschen vorbei.
Ja, aber er kommen die Zeit der Volksparteien, das wäre jetzt auch schon seit zwanzig Jahren, ja? Äh, die Volksparteien, die Volksparteien, die Volksparteien, also das, lass uns das mal äh vielleicht für einen späteren äh Teil
übrig lassen. Ich finde äh die Wahl wird ja jetzt genug äh auseinandergenommen, was da alles für eine Scheiße immer reininterpretiert wird. Ich kann's schon nicht mehr hören, was da nicht der Wählerwille, der Wählerwille, ja äh Armin Laschet erzählt mir einen vom Wählerwillen, ja. Der Wählerwille ist, Armin Laschet, geh bitte.
Der Wählerwille, ne.
Darauf kann man sich einigen.
Über alles andere, alles andere ist Theorie, ja? Äh Spiel dauert neunzig Minuten, Ball ist rund. So, aber äh.
Und am Ende gewinnt Deutschland.
Okay, kommen wir mal, kommen wir mal zu den anderen äh Gewinnen, die Deutschland so eingeheimst hat. Am Ende der letzten Sendung.
Haben wir uns die App ID Wallet angeschaut.
Und ähm sind beide, sage ich mal, nicht, haben beide nicht die Gelegenheit gehabt, diese App durchzuspielen,
ja? Weil wir äh innerhalb kürzester Zeit an einem äh ja, so einem Wartewarterättchen scheiterten, wenn wir versucht haben, die irgendwie äh zu starten. Also die App war nicht,
funktional.
Also bei mir ist das Warterädchen dann irgendwann auch weggegangen, aber ich äh kam dann aus anderen Gründen nicht weiter.
Ja genau, also das äh die diese App wurde war einfach, äh denke ich, muss man sagen, die war einfach nicht, nicht, nicht funktional. Ähm,
Woraufhin sich dann mal.
Einige Leute so ganz grundsätzlich mal äh diese App angeschaut haben. Und es ging dann damit los, dass,
dass man dann so feststellt, okay, was sind denn hier der der der verantwortliche Name, der die Zonen verwaltet, der hat ja irgendwie so ungefähr einmal alle Ports offen, die es gibt, inklusive seiner Datenbank, äh die Server, auf denen das gehostet
wird dieses sowohl Ding sind irgendwie.
Bei Hetzner und da ist außerdem noch irgendein Pizzaservice mit drauf, also so so wirklich, richtig.
Richtig, richtig peinlich.
Und dann haben äh hat sich noch herausgestellt, das war jetzt gar nichts so neu ist, dass äh das macht sie jetzt aber auch nicht nicht äh schlimmer, äh nicht besser.
Was diese App ja machen soll, ist, dass du dass du dich ähm.
Ausweist gegenüber einer anderen Stelle. Und jetzt muss man vielleicht einmal noch kurz daran erinnern, wir.
Haben das ja. Also wir können uns ja äh ausweisen. Wir haben ja die EID Funktion und die schon seit sehr langer Zeit, ja, inzwischen glaube ich, ist das bald soweit, dass das alle Menschen.
In Deutschland so neuen Personalausweis haben, müsste also bald soweit sein, weil irgendwann laufen die Alten ja ab. Das heißt, die die Adaptionsrate, Adoptionsrate des neuen Perso müsste eigentlich,
schon sehr, sehr hoch sein in Deutschland. Und mit dem kann man,
elektronisch äh signieren, mit dem kann man sich ausweisen und das sind funktionierende Verfahren, ja, die.
Leider nie ähm angenommen wurden, ja oder die, die quasi keine Verbreitung gefunden haben. Und das scheint ja hier der Grund gewesen zu sein.
Dass man ähm.
Dass man sich für diese andere App da entschieden hat, die, und das muss man einfach mal ganz klar sagen, von der existierenden,
EID oder äh überhaupt E-Person, ein ein aktives Downgrade ist. Ja, also wieder einmal und ich möchte jetzt hier spezifisch,
Bezüge zu anderen Verfahren herstellen. Wieder einmal wird.
Ein etablierter Sicherheitsstandard, quasi absichtlich geschwächt, um ein neues Verfahren zu etablieren, ja? Und die Frage ist, ob diese absichtliche Schwächung.
Notwendig ist oder ähm ob sie einfach aus Inkompetenz kommt.
Ja, diejenigen, die sagen, diese Schwächung äh wäre notwendig. Sie gehen davon aus, dass die im Prinzip, ja, das ist ja die, dass sie quasi eine Unweigerlichkeit der Vereinfachung ist. Ja, also wir müssen das einfacher machen, sonst nutzt es ja keiner. Wir haben ja gesehen,
sicheren Verfahren sind zu sicher. Das ist so ein bisschen quasi die Argumentation, äh die man da hört. Ähm,
Dem würde ich entgegenhalten, wenn ich ein Projekt,
bauen möchte für die Zukunft, dann sollte ich zumindest natürlich den aktuellen Stand der Technik schon mal gewissenhaft umsetzen.
Was war hier der Fall? Also die die Schwachstelle, die diesem System inne wohnt, ist, du kannst, also,
diejenige Person, die sich ausweist, ja, die weist sich ja dann quasi aus und übermittelt quasi sie von der Bundesdruckerei, signierte Daten und sagt, ich bin diese äh ich bin.
Oder dies ist ein gültiger Personalausweis, ja, mit folgenden Daten.
Jetzt ist aber die Frage, wem gegenüber weißt du dich denn aus? Und da gibt es verschiedene Spielmodi in diesem Protokoll, was die verwenden. Und der eine Modus ist folgender. Das scannt einen QR-Code,
Und in diesem QR-Code steht drin, wem gegenüber du dich ausweist und an welchen Endpunkt im Internet diese Daten geschickt werden sollen.
Das steht im QR-Code.
Was da aber still im QR-Code, ja. Was da aber nicht drin steht ist irgendein Beweis dafür, dass die,
Die Instanz der gegenüber du dich jetzt ausweist auch wirklich diejenige ist, die du möchtest, weil der Endpunkt, den kann ich ja frei bestimmen. Also mit anderen Worten, du kannst dir einen QR-Code machen.
In dem drin steht, du bist ähm hell gebraun, ja, oder du bist äh David Hasselhoff.
Oder der Verfassungsschutz.
Oder oder äh das Hotel, in dem die Leute einchecken und gibt's als Endpunkt, wo die Daten hingeschickt werden sollen an äh Linus Neumann DE Slash Datensammlung.
Mhm.
Und dann, alles was dort ankommt, schickst du dann aber zeitgleich einfach an den richtigen Endpunkt. Ja, also der Angriff in Anführungszeichen wäre, du überklebst äh irgendwo die äh die QR-Codes,
ja? Jetzt kann man natürlich argumentieren und so würde ich auch argumentieren, ein solcher Angriff ist ähm nicht,
Es ist nicht davon auszugehen, dass ein solcher Angriff in großer Menge stattfindet. Ja, ähm.
Der überwiegende äh in der im überwiegenden.
Mehrheit der Fälle wird das einfach nicht passieren. Ja, also du müsstest, klar, du kannst jetzt irgendwie äh den,
den den QR-Code in irgendein Hotel oder sowas überkleben, ja und vielleicht fällt's auch keinem auf und dann hast du eine Schwachstelle demonstriert, aber das Verfahren wird jetzt daran nicht sterben, ja? Trotzdem.
Baut man natürlich kein Verfahren, dass eine offenkundige konzeptionelle Schwäche hat, die,
bekannt ist. Da gibt's ja oft Gitthup schon Monate oder Jahre alte Diskussionen zu, die sagen, hier
Protokoll hat folgenden Angriffsvektor
und dem muss man begegnen. Und da sagen dann die die Entwickler quasi so, ja äh stimmt, aber äh den betrachten wir als nicht relevant. Und so baust du natürlich nicht ein System, wo du sagst, das wird jetzt irgendwie in.
Das soll jetzt die äh Zukunft äh für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland sein, ja. Und tja, ich meine.
Äh es ist einfach nur peinlich, ne. Dann, dass diese App nicht funktioniert hat,
lag ja daran, dass sie äh, also sie haben dann gesagt, dass sie, ist eigentlich ganz lustig, dass sie unter der ähm unter der Last des des hohen Interesses ähm,
zusammengebrochen wäre, ja?
Und äh ja, das kann man äh so sagen, ne. Jetzt ist halt die, also wenn dein System zusammenbricht unter dem äh unter dem äh Interesse, dann gibt's,
zwei Möglichkeiten. Das Interesse ist wirklich richtig groß oder deine Ressourcen sind,
Einfach total lächerlich klein. Ähm Henrik.
Ähm hat dazu äh getwittert und das finde ich auch sehr schön. Also ID Wallet nochmal zum Mitschreiben, dass ich das richtig verstanden habe. Man nimmt eine staatliche E,
die mit einigen kryptographischen Handwerk so designt wurde, dass A für jede Datenfreigabe die anfordernde Partei zweifel zwei identifiziert werden kann und B an keiner Stelle extern verifizierbare Datensätze anfallen,
um daraus dann eine sogenannte Identity abzuleiten, die A dadurch entsteht, dass sie von der Bundesdruckerei signiert wird
B aus wertvollen signierten Personen bezogenen Daten besteht und C, bei der man nicht mehr sehen kann, wen man sie übermittelt. Also hier eine sehr genau zusammengefasst, was hier gerade geschwächt wurde, ne, gegenüber einem bestehenden System. Und dann abschließend,
Das Ganze auf einer Infrastruktur, die es gerade mal geschafft hat, im mittleren vierstelligen Bereich. All dies auszustellen,
Insgesamt nicht pro Sekunde, bevor sie zusammenbrach.
Ja, den ist er direkt noch außen vor. Ähm.
Aber so und dann gehen die hin und, und, und, und, und sagen dann auch noch beschwichtigen dann auch noch und fühlen sich irgendwie cool, dass dass ihr System da äh irgendwie geil wäre, ne? Der Server, auf dem das lief,
hat irgendwie FDP, SSH, SMTP, HTTP Pop drei, IMAP, RSH, HTPS, S MTPS Sub Mission, allen möglichen Shit an Ports of My SQL und Postkress,
außen freigegeben, ja? Das ist einfach der Server von Digital Endabling Punkt EU.
Ich hab's schon geahnt, dass ich den Namen gelesen habe.
So und und und es ist halt einfach nur ein eine absolute Peinlichkeit. Es ist die, also so etwas,
zu launchen, ja? Und dann müssen sie nicht mal,
einen Tag platt äh einen Tag platt kann dir ja passieren, ja. Äh Herrje, ne, sondern die sind jetzt auf Wochen offline und und müssen quasi sagen, okay, dieses Ding ist komplett gefailt. Stimmt?
Und wir werden jetzt nochmal ein paar Monate investieren. Die haben die App sogar aus dem App Store wieder rausgezogen. Ja, das heißt, die haben du, du kannst die gar nicht mehr kriegen.
Ja? Also so eine richtige, richtige Bauchlandung. Nicht irgendwie nur so ein bisschen, sondern eine richtige Bauchlandung. Und dann gibt es ähm.
Gab's jetzt irgendwie, das ist glaube ich auch so ein bisschen blöd geskettelt gewesen. Gab's irgendwie am äh zweiten Oktober, wenn ich das richtig erinnere oder war das am? Nee, am Ersten, äh am am Freitag.
Von der vom BSI BSI irgendwie so eine Veranstaltung zur Identitys. Ich schätze mal, die hatten sich jetzt, sage ich mal, den Rahmen der Veranstaltung etwas anders vorgestellt. Wenn die halt ein paar Tage nach diesem Launch ist und der ist aber halt dann gefailt.
Ja? Und dann findest du da Leute, die so ähm äh sinngemäß sagen, also
die halt beschwichtigen und die dann so Sätze sagen wie 99 Prozent Sicherheit muss ausreichen, es muss nicht immer 100 Prozent sein und wenn der CCC was findet, ist das ja gut, dann fixen wir das und dann können die weiter gucken. Aber am Ende ist das hier ein
ein cooles System. Und zu dieser, zu dieser Haltung muss ich jetzt mal wirklich sagen, die gefällt mir halt,
überhaupt nicht.
Das, was sie da gelauncht haben, als 99 Prozent sicher zu bezeichnen, ist ein Witz für alles, was 99 Prozent ist und alles, was sicher ist, ja? Ähm das ist einfach, also das war einfach nur
äh eine eine absolut peinliche Bauchlandung. Ähm zweitens zu sagen.
Also bekannte Schwachstellen, die will man einfach nicht haben, auch und das muss ich wirklich sagen, ja, da da muss ich auch wirklich anmachen. Dieser Angriff mit dem falschen QR-Code, der wird jetzt nicht,
so nicht so viel.
Passt nicht so große Rolle spielen. Aber mal als Beispiel ähm wenn du bei so einer hoheitlichen App am anderen Ende etwas stehen hast, dann glaubst du das ja auch. Das heißt, hier entstehen ja noch andere Verfahren, der der.
Machen kannst, wenn du beispielsweise in der Lage bist, dich mit deiner äh mit deinem Request als sagen wir mal die Polizei Niedersachsen auszugeben, ja? Und am anderen Ende die Leute, die dann quasi ihre Daten absenden.
Denken dann, oh ja, krass, hier in der Führerschein-App steht, äh, dass dass der, der Typ geht mir gegenüber Polizist ist.
Und dass dass die Menschen natürlich diese Dinge auch nicht verstehen, ja? Wir müssen ja immer auch überlegen, wir veröffentlichen ähm Technologien,
geben die hier zur Anwendung, die die Menschen nicht verstehen.
Und da muss man natürlich sagen, man setzt äh man sollte natürlich den jede Schwachstelle, die das System hat, egal ob von erhöhter praktischer Relevanz oder theoretischer Natur, die muss man natürlich ausmerzen. Ja.
Und Security wird eh nicht in Prozent äh gemessen, sondern das hat auch Christian Köntop, der da äh einen sehr guten äh Twitter-Fread zu hat, den wir auch ähm verlinkt haben.
Er sagt eben nicht, ne, Prozente sind schwierig bei Security, ein kompromittiertes System ist ja nicht dreiundvierzig Prozent gehackt, sondern hundert Prozent im Eimer. Ja, das heißt, man muss äh man kann hier gar nicht in Prozenten äh sprechen. Ähm.
Ist nicht viel bei der Impfung. Also vor allem und und was es halt auch noch mit sich bringt, jeder Bericht über,
Das konnte äh auf diese Art und Weise kompromittiert werden oder hier kann man den Aussagen nicht trauen, die.
Füttern natürlich dann auch das allgemeine Misstrauen gegenüber dieser Technologie und dann ihrer potenziellen Anwendung, die dann dazu führt, dass eben die
potentiell segensreichen Anwendungen, die das ja dann auch haben kann, dann am Ende nicht akzeptiert werden. Und von daher muss man eben
im ersten Schritt schon mal wirklich maximal safe vorangehen und nicht sagen, ach
passt auch hier irgendwie 99 Prozent. Ja, Pi mal Daumen, äh das ist einfach nicht der richtige Ansatz. So geht man IT-Projekte nicht an und schon gar nicht IT-Projekte, die halt wirklich so auf Bundesebene dann äh oder auf europäischer Ebene sogar eine Rolle spielen sollen, wenn nicht sogar weltweit.
Und jetzt kommt äh natürlich auch noch dieser äh dieser Aspekt hinzu, auch da, da zitiere ich jetzt auch nochmal hier Christian Köto, der eben auch sagt.
Wie dann eben damit umgegangen wird. So, ja, der CCC hat was gefunden, ne? Überleg dir mal bitte, also so sehr ich,
an dieser Stelle hier Fabian Lübke und Lilith Wittmann, die sich das angeschaut haben und da eben,
diese Schwachstellen niedergeschrieben und veröffentlicht haben,
dass sie das getan haben, muss man immer noch mal dazu sagen. Das haben die in ihrer Freizeit getan, ne? Das sind äh irgendwie junge Menschen, die eine neue App kriegen und da einen Tag draufgucken
und dann katastrophale Designfehler finden,
Das ist nicht, da kannst du nicht sagen, ja, ja, der CCC findet was und wenn der was gefunden hat, ist das super. Vielen Dank CC, ja? Sorry,
ich möchte bitte, dass Sachen veröffentlicht werden, die nicht an einem Tag beim ersten drauf.
Sofort in katastrophalen Dingen untergehen. Ja und da sagt äh äh twittert äh Christian auch zu,
Der CCC ist mein Sicherheitscheck. Nein, ist der nicht. Als ich zuletzt nachgeschaut habe, war der CCC eine Vereinigung von Leuten mit dem Ziel, Spaß am Gerät zu haben
Das kann auch dein Gerät sein, aber das ersetzt kein Sicherheitskonzept. Ein Sicherheitskonzept würde erstens ein organisatorisches und inhaltliches Konzept für die Anwendung haben,
Zweitens, ein Prozess, der das dann in der Entwicklung umsetzt und testet, drittens, ein eben solches Konzept für den Betrieb.
Ähm,
dann ein Prozess, der das dann wiederum umsetzt. Und ganz wichtig, einen Plan, der umgesetzt wird, wenn dann doch etwas schief geht. Das ist so selbstverständlich, dass es uns zu einem nächsten Punkt bringt, da kommt dann auch noch drauf, den lasse ich jetzt mal kurz weg, aus, aufgrund der Breite.
Ähm du willst weißt du,
Wenn da jemand hingeht und sagt, das wird jetzt hier die, das wird die Identitätsverwaltung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland mit mit der Bundesdruckerei an Bord und hasse alles nicht gesehen, ne. Jetzt wird's
endlich digital, Tim, jetzt, jetzt bricht dir die die der Digitalismus aus, ja? Ähm,
Und dann ist das auf irgendeine Hetzenerbüchs von irgendwelchen von irgendwelchen Amateuren gehostet, die noch nicht mal ihre ihre Datenbanken nur lokal laufen lassen.
Kriegen, echt.
So und dann kommen Leute, die ja auch dieser, die ja tatsächlich auch beruflich andere Dinge machen, ja? Und sagen, ach das ist ja interessant. Komm, ich gucke mal kurz drauf, ach.
Vorm ersten Kaffee, so morgen.
Kann doch nicht sein, ja, der erste Kaffee schon irgendwie schmeckt nicht mehr, weil er wieder irgendso einen Mister findest, ne. So, das kann doch nicht der Anspruch sein. So, das das ist doch wirklich, das ist doch nur zum Heulen. Und jetzt komme ich mal ein bisschen auf diese.
Auf die Metaebene.
Und ich glaube, dass hier etwas ganz anderes zu Grunde liegt, warum diese Sachen immer kaputt gehen. Und der Gedanke dazu ist mir so ein bisschen gekommen, als ich hier am Wochenende nochmal vom
Deutschlandfunk, Computer und Kommunikation zu D Mail,
befragt wurde, ja? Und da habe ich dann nochmal so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht so, was ist eigentlich, also bei der D-Mail, es ging ja damals.
Ähm um E-Government und. Ja, das also die wollten quasi Government ist dann so alles, was Verwaltung ist und Justice ist eben alles, was Justiz ist und die haben gesagt, wir möchten quasi die Prozesse der Justiz.
Und die Prozesse der Verwaltung gerne digitalisieren,
Und ne, damit man nicht immer, was weiß ich, den Hartz vier Antrag und was weiß ich alles, einen Brief schicken möchte, möchten wir jetzt eine D-Mail haben. So, das war, das war quasi die Zielsetzung der DML.
Und.
Quasi die Prozesse von Verwaltung und Justiz digitalisieren. Und die Idee, die denen gekommen ist, war zu sagen, geil, wir machen einfach ein E-Mail-System.
Ja? Weil wir ja alle wissen, alle die professionell mit Computern arbeiten, dass E-Mail so richtig geil ist.
Ist es überhaupt das solideste System? Ich meine, Alter, das gibt's von Anfang an. Das gibt's immer noch, das muss gut sein.
So und äh und jetzt denk mal, also denk mal, äh ähm darüber nach, wie kompliziert.
Aber wie auch.
Ähm einheitlich die Prozesse einer Verwaltung sind oder die Prozesse äh äh einer Justiz. So, da da kann man.
Wenn man möchte, richtige Verfahren zur Digitalisierung bauen
Ja, also man kann ja zum Beispiel sagen, okay, ähm ich spinne jetzt nur rum, ne. Das ist also man kann jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, okay, wir machen eine äh Webseite,
bei der du diese äh Anträge machen kannst und dann werden die Anträge
des Antragsformular ist einfach digital da. Am Ende signierst du das mit deinem Personalausweis und reißt das über unser Verwaltungsportal ein.
Da können wir dir eine Handreichung machen, eine digitale äh Erläuterung, wie dieser Antrag auszufüllen ist, was fehlt und so weiter. Und du könntest quasi so einen richtig schönen.
Digitalen Prozess machen, der dann nämlich den Vorteil hätte, dass er auf der anderen Seite, nämlich dem empfangenen Amt,
die Daten auch strukturiert in der Form senden würde, wie sie die brauchen und dann weiterverarbeiten können. So arbeiten ja digitalisierte Unternehmen, ja, wenn du jetzt also neben mir ein digitales äh Unternehmen wie Amazon
Wenn ich dort etwas bestelle, dann übersetzt meine Bestellung direkt bei denen durch, bis
hinzu auf einem Tablett von einer Hilfskraft steht, in welches Regal die gehen muss
um das Objekt zu nehmen, was ich bestellt habe und in welchen Karton die das packen muss und in welche Kiste das dann kommt, damit das jemand nächsten Tag bei mir vor der Haustür fährt,
ja? Das ist ein digitales Unternehmen. Wenn Amazon sagen würde, wir nehmen jetzt auch Bestellungen per D Mail entgegen.
Dann wären die nicht in der Lage, diese Leistungen zu erbringen, weil
Dieses Übergabeformat halt wieder vollständig undefiniert ist und dann hast du halt einfach nichts zu Ende gebaut. Du hast du hast nichts du hast dich drüber nachgedacht.
Keine Spezifikation, keine API, keine.
Du hast keine Spezifikation und diese und dann ist nämlich der, da gibt's diesen, diesen klassischen Ausspruch. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, von wem der ist, vielleicht auch einfach schon Verfasser unbekannt,
Wenn du einen Scheißprozess digitalisierst, dann hast du einen digitalen Scheißprozess. Und das ist genau das mit dem mit was mit der D-Mail eben definiert war, dass da am Ende das Beste, was man mit D-Mail hinkriegen konnte, war.
Dass dass dann ein PDF-Anhang ist, den man ausdrucken muss. Das ist ja nicht der Beginn einer digitalen Aktenführung.
Das ist das Ende.
Ja? Das ist das Ende einer digitalen Aktenführung, ja. Bitte, bitte denken sie nach, bevor sie diese DML ausdrucken, ja? Und dann musste dich dann musst du dich nicht wundern.
Dass die Gerichte das Verfahren nur zögerlich adaptieren, dass äh die Unternehmen das Verfahren nur zögerlich adaptieren,
das am Ende nach acht oder zehn Jahren oder was? Äh die Deutsche Telekom sagt, ey nein, packen wir aus, macht das aus! Dieses was wir da als D-Mail-Server betreiben, äh das eitelt nur rum, ja? Wir müssen jetzt, wir müssen das ausschalten
So, das ist ja ganz klar, weil hier nicht,
sinnvoll mal überlegt wurde, was möchten wir hier eigentlich tun? Und das ist mit dieser Wallet-ID äh AID Wallet ja auch wieder der Punkt, dass man sie nämlich nicht darüber nachgedacht hat, wie kann man das jetzt hier mal anbinden? So, was soll das am Ende überhaupt?
Was soll das? Und diese Frage muss man sich vorher stellen. Bevor man zum Beispiel, wie jetzt hier in Deutschland sagt, jetzt machen wir Blockchain-Zeugnis.
Die Kinder sitzen ohne Maske in der Schule ähm haben keinen Computer, kein gar nix und äh und verblöden.
Und und und jetzt brauchen wir einen Blockchain-Zeugnis, weil wir ja alle wissen, wie dramatisch das Problem ist, dass wir kein Blockchain-Zeugnis haben.
Oder überhaupt kein digitales Zeugnis.
Leiden, die Kinder sitzen da in der Schule und sagen, boah ey, ich quäle mich hier durch den ganzen Scheiß und am Ende habe ich so ein unsicheres Zeugnis, was noch nicht mal in der Blockchain ist.
Kinder Tim, die kommen doch auch jeden Tag nach Hause und und haben eine Sinnkrise, weil sie kein, kein. Und es wäre.
Ja, ich weiß ja auch gar nicht, wie ich das, wie ich das Zeugnis überhaupt ordentlich verifizieren soll. Also, ich habe da so ein Stück Papier irgendwie, die können mir ja irgendwas erzählen. Ja, wenn ich nicht.
Dein Sohn wäre in der 5ten Klasse.
Wenn das nicht mit Bitcoin abgesichert ist, dann dann halte ich das ist doch nix wert. Und.
Und und weißt du, wie einfach es wäre, digitale Zeugnisse zu machen, ne? Dann und ich kann's nur nochmal.
Nimmst du eine PKI, von mir aus, von der Bundesdruckerei oder von einer äh vom Bildungsminister, von wem auch immer, ja? Und dann signierst du die fucking Zeugnisse. Und dann gibst du den Leuten
PDF mit einer eingebetteten Signatur,
und dann kann man sich das PDF an aufmachen und dann steht da, dieses PDF wurde signiert von der Bundesrepublik Deutschland höchstpersönlich äh Joachim Gauck oder wer auch immer. Christian Wulf äh äh gratuliert
zur Abiturklasse zweitausendneunzehn oder irgend so ein Scheiß, weißt du, das kannst.
Und wie viel genau und wie viel muss und wie viel neue Software muss dafür geschrieben werden? Keine, wie viel neue Spezifikationen müssen dafür durchgesetzt werden.
Keine. Ist alles schon da. Es exist,
alles schon. Stattdessen wird jetzt wieder irgend so eine Startup Bode, die irgendwie ihnen lang genug in den Kopf reingeredet hat, dass sie um irgendwie die Blockchain
Initiative äh der Bundesrepublik Deutschland muss ja jetzt auf Früchte tragen und ist ja viel geiler, wenn das, wenn das Zeugnis in der Block drin steht. Und dann kann ich halt einfach nur sagen, was
immer sagen, wenn es um das Thema Blockchain geht. Warum,
weswegen, weshalb, wozu? Es ist vollkommen unklar, warum muss wozu braucht es eine Blockchain? Was wird durch eine Blockchain ermöglicht,
Nichts.
Ich meine, man muss dazu sagen, Tim, Leute, Leute, die Datenbanken so gut verstanden haben, dass sie auf einem Server Postgress und my SGL nach.
Beide gleich.
Vorteil von der Blockchain, ja, weil.
Nur kurz, wir hatten in der letzten Sendung ja darüber gesprochen, dass es diese eine App gab, die direkt äh auf die Datenbank zugegriffen hat, wo der.
Das macht man nicht. Die Datenbank hat lokal zu laufen. Aber okay, lass es. Ich möchte noch kurz hier zum zum Stand der Digitalisierung ein ein kleines Beispiel geben, warum ich ihnen sage so sinnvoll wäre,
sich zu überlegen, was haben wir überhaupt für Prozesse, ja.
Und wie möchten wir die abbilden? Und jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Antragswesen, da würde ich tatsächlich sagen, äh das würde ich wirklich mit einem Webportal machen,
Was äh wo du am Ende,
quasi deine Willensbekundung mit der EID signierst und fertig, ne? Da da hast du so richtig krass Digital so. Und dann können Leute, die haben da die gesamten direkt digital vorliegen und können damit arbeiten. Dann kannst du wirklich so ein digitales ähm.
Kommunikationswesen bauen, aber das geht halt immer oder also sauber definierte Prozesse bedeuten eben, dass du auch genau weißt, was du am Ende willst. Ja und ähm jetzt habe ich hier von einem Kumpel ein Beispiel bekommen,
der hat also der hatte ein Gerichtsverfahren.
Und ähm äh hat in dem Rahmen dieses Gerichtsverfahren wurde Akteneinsicht verlangt, ja? Und,
Dieser Prozess, den es da gibt, der nennt sich dann
E-Hilfsakte, also ganz klassisch, ne, wenn du äh wenn du irgendwie im Rahmen eines äh eines solchen Verfahren bist, äh dann darf dein Anwalt
oder deine Anwältin ja Akteneinsicht verlangen, dann gibt's quasi alles, was da irgendwie so an Beweisen und Aussagen und und Beschuldigungen oder was auch immer zusammen formuliert wurde, ist ja dann quasi eine Akte.
So und früher war das dann so, dann bist du halt da hingegangen, hast dir die Akte geben lassen, hast dir einmal übern Kopierer gescheucht, ja und äh dann warst du fertig. So, heute wird das digital gemacht.
Und hier liegt jetzt dieser Akteneinsicht, eine äh eine äh eine Kommunikation bei.
Die sehr äh interessant ist. Ich lese das mal vor. Hinweis zu Akteneinsicht, ihnen wird,
Einsicht auf elektronischem Weg in die sogenannte E-Hilfsakte gewährt. Neu angelegte Ehehilfsakten werden seit dem 102220 nicht mehr in der Form ein Band,
gleich ein PDF-Dokument erstellt, sondern in der Form ein Dokument gleich ein PDF-Dokument. So, das bedeutet.
Früher, vor dem ersten, zweiundzwanzig hast du ein PDF bekommen, da war einfach chronologisch die gesamte Akte drin,
Hast du genommen, hast auf drucken gedrückt, ne? Und dann hattest du quasi die Akte von vorne nach hinten, wahrscheinlich einmal durch den Einzugsscanner gescannt und hattest quasi die chronologisch vorliegen.
Jetzt bekommst du,
EinzelpDFs und so eine Akte kann natürlich aus 20, dreißig, zweihundert, fünfhundert Einzeldokumenten bestehen.
Die du jetzt in diesem Fall einzeln bekommst. Und das stellt natürlich die Anwältin und Anwälte vor ein Problem, weil.
Sie jetzt potenziell diese ganzen Dateien einzeln drucken müssen. Ja? Und,
natürlich auch nicht unbedingt sichergestellt ist, dass sie die dann chronologisch haben
Wie es bei der Akte eben der Fall wäre. Und das ist natürlich ein Problem, wenn du sagst, hier sind die 200 Dokumente. Du weißt aber nicht, in welcher du musst sie jetzt erstmal Zeitaufwand bringen, um die äh zu sortieren.
Ne? Dann ist das für dich ein Problem. Deswegen ist diesem Hinweis zu Akteneinsicht folgender Text hinzugefügt. Vorsorglich wird mitgeteilt,
dass ein Anspruch auf Übermittlung der Elf Elf.
In besonderer Form nicht besteht, solange die gewährte Form zur effektiven Verteidigung ausreichend ist. Siehe Bundestagsdrucksache, achtzehnvierundneunzig sechzehn, Seite siebenundfünfzig.
Eine Beeinträchtigung der effektiven Verteidigung droht schon deshalb nicht, weil sie die EinzelpDF-Dokumente mittels eines frei verfügbaren PDF-Konverters jederzeit zu einer gesamt Datei zusammenführen können.
Also, hier gibt's quasi eine.
Vorsorgliche äh Mitteilung, dass du nicht von dieser Staatsanwaltschaft verlangen kannst, dass sie dir ein PDF schicken, weil du kannst ja diese EinzelpDF ähm mit wieder zu einem,
großen Zusammenfügen. Und jetzt kommt's,
Folgende PDF-Konverter sind unter anderem frei verfügbar. HTTP small PDF Punkt com. Tools Punkt PDF 24 Punkt org.
PDF Dot com Schrägstrich DE. I love PDF Dot com Schrägstrich DE und PDF zusammen Fuegen Punkt com. So.
Alter. Was? Bitte geht ab! Oh nein!
Und da sagt jetzt die, die Staatsanwaltschaft sagt jetzt quasi den ähm den Anwältinnen.
Doch mal deine geheimen Akten auf irgend so einem Hoschiser hoch.
Alter Falter. Oh Gott, ist das traurig. Oh.
Und in dieser Welt.
Nein.
Kommen wir und sagen mit dem mit dem ist das jetzt gelöst. Ja und oder mit ID Wallet oder sowas, ja? Und jetzt langer langer Rede kurzer Sinn.
D Mail, ID Wallet, diese E-Hilfsakte, die Blockchain-Zeugnis, das besondere elektronische Anwaltspostfach und wie die ganzen Fales.
Nicht alle heißen, die sind ähm immer so Einzelinitiativen.
Die ähm die quasi nicht
zu Ende gedacht haben, was da wirklich was sie da wirklich eigentlich digitalisieren wollen. Und da wird quasi ein, ein, ein, ein absolut
inherrent analoge Institutionen irgendein digitaler Kanal hingebaut.
Ja und das ist, das kann nicht funktionieren.
Das kann nicht funktionieren und vor allem dem Ganzen fehlt einfach eines äh,
Du hast es auch schon gesagt, dem Ganzen fehlt einfach eine Strategie. Bevor man irgendeinen dieser Prozesse beginnt, so wie man das in jedem Unternehmen auch machen würde, denkt man sich erstmal darüber nach, okay
Was haben wir für Prozesse? Wie wollen wir, dass diese Prozesse eigentlich funktionieren
weil sie ja in einer digitalen Welt auf einmal nicht mehr in diesen ganzen Constrates des der manuellen Arbeit festhängt. Das schafft ja eine ganze Menge äh Möglichkeiten, ne? Online-Authentifizierung et cetera, Automatisierung auch generell,
dann baut man sich seine Datentypen, da baut man sich seine Strukturen, baut man sich seine seine seine Protokolle äh ab und und schafft einfach Schnittstellen. Und da muss man auch nicht sich von irgend so einer
dahergelaufenen Hoschi Bude so eine schnell zusammengetackerte App machen und dann ist die App irgendwie äh die Lösung für alles, sondern man schafft halt einfach APIs und man schafft einfach ein ein ein digitalen Zugang
den im Prinzip jede App machen kann. Und wenn ich dann irgendwie meinen äh Auto ummelden will, dann gibt's dafür auch irgendwie passende Apps, die halt einfach gegen die,
ähm APIs,
der Fahrzeugzulassungsbehörde arbeiten wie alle anderen das auch tun und man kann es in Webseiten einbauen, man kann das automatisieren und so weiter. Aber die Authentifizierung und die Sicherung.
Sicherung der Identitäten ist sichergestellt, weil eben einfach ordentliche
Standard Prozeduren verwendet werden, um mit einem mit einem Personalausweis das online durchzuführen, ohne dass da nochmal irgendeine neue
Sicherheitsschwankungen eingebaut wird, die von irgend so einer komischen Firma abhängt
und nur so kann es gehen und nur so kann es eben funktionieren, wenn man den ganzen Staat noch mal von Grund auf digital neu denkt. Und wenn diese neue Regierung jetzt äh es wieder nicht schafft, ein, ein, ein,
zu schaffen oder zumindest eine Struktur in der so das digitale einfach so ist, dann wird es halt auch weiterhin nichts werden. Also ich ich
Persönlich denke, ohne so ein Digitalministerium, was eine ähnliche Rolle spielt, wie ein Finanzministerium, also was überall mit reinreden darf. Ja, und was einfach mal die ganze Sache für sich genommen, komplett neu plant und das wird auch lange dauern, gar keine Frage. Also jetzt haben wir die die Zeit schon verloren, nur all das, was wir jetzt bisher geschaffen haben.
So teuer das gewesen sein mag, so schade das irgendwie ist, dass da Arbeit so viel geleistet wurde, die eigentlich für nichts gut ist, der ganze Scheiß muss weg.
Schmeißt eure Blockchain-Zeugnisse ins Feuer, ja, DE-Mail verbrennt es, eure elektronische Hilfsakte, was auch immer ihr euch äh fallen habt
lassen, all die, all diese ganzen Sachen
schmeißt es einfach alles weg oder ignoriert es zumindest erstmal und baut es neu und dann
werden sich die Dinge zusammenfinden. Und das wird nochmal zehn Jahre dauern. Wir werden der Welt noch lange hinterher hüpfen und irgendwie uns von Estland und Georgien vormachen lassen, wie irgendwie ein moderner Staat funktioniert. So, aber dann,
besteht, zumindest am Ende die Hoffnung, dass es dann funktioniert und man nicht wieder irgendeine Kacke wegschmeißen muss und man sinnlose Unternehmen durchgefüttert hat, die am Ende überhaupt nichts für die Gemeinheit beitragen.
Und hier und jetzt nur halt nur um dir mal kurz zu also wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen, wer hat dieses Ding, wer hat dieses Ding verwurstet, ne, das ist ja, geht eigentlich auf Dorothee Bär zurück
und dann irgendwie Andi Scheuer, der ist dann, also ne, ich meine, da kannst du dir auch dann weißt ja schon, warum das nix ist, ne? Aber,
Dorothee Bär sagt dann, die Zweifel am Reifegrad der Technik teile ich nicht.
Sorry, mit welcher Kompetenz ja und jetzt pass auf.
Sie ist froh, wenn wir bei einer Innovation mal vor die Welle kommen.
Es ist schon ein seltsamer Vorwurf, dass man zu innovativ sei.
Also mal ganz ehrlich, den Vorwurf.
Dass ihr zu innovativ seid. Den habt ihr euch, glaube ich, also die einzigen, die den erheben, ne, die sitzen wahrscheinlich bei euch in der Partei,
ja? Das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass die diesen Vorwurf erheben. Vor die Welle, ja, äh, äh, man möchte auf der Welle sein, nicht vor der Welle
So, das ist so, also ich meine, vor der Welle ist da, wo die halt auch dann über dich hereinbricht und mit irgendwie zwanzig Pods
offen und nicht mal 1tausend tausend all dies Last äh abfedern zu können, das ist nicht vor der Welle,
Das ist unter der Welle. Das ist ganz tief unten im Wasser. Wohl keine Luft mehr kriegst. Da bist du nicht irgendwie vor der Welle. Das ist wirklich und oder soll ich innovativ. Hör mal.
Steckt im Klärwerk fest, ey.
Das ist wirklich eine ein also und man ey das ist tut auch so weh. Weißt du was?
Muss man ja auch sehen. So, jetzt hier, jetzt kommen wir als CCC und sagen seit Jahren, ihr baut immer nur Kacke, ihr wollt immer nur kacke, macht das doch mal ordentlich, ne? Dann sagst du denen, hier, da sind Sicherheitslücken drin,
dann sagen die, hä, das wissen wir schon. Ja, aber du sagst, ja hat der Geil, warum hat das denn dann gebaut? Das wird doch nicht dafür, dadurch besser, dass eure Entwickler das schon auf Gitter auf als,
haben. So, da da muss man doch aufschrecken, wenn man so etwas sieht, ja? Äh und dann nicht sagen, nee, wir müssen hier jetzt vor die Welle kommen, Leute,
wir launchen jetzt hier diese diese Wurst, diese Wurst und äh und und und dann dann sind aber alle doof,
die gesagt haben, dass das Mist ist. Und äh dass wir den Scheiß jetzt aus dem App-Store rausnehmen müssen. Und das ist aber, weil das zu innovativ war. Ich meine, wie wie verzehrt kannst du denn wahrnehmen, dass du jetzt da sitzt und sagst, oh schade, dass wir zu innovativ waren.
Ähm und und der ganze kackt nicht funktioniert hat, weil wir vor der Welle waren, so eine, so eine Peinlichkeit.
Das ist einfach echt.
Und, und, und am anderen Ende sitzen dann nämlich am anderen Ende von diesem Ding sitzen, sitzen,
ne, in in bei der Polizei und in der Verwaltung irgendwelche.
Armen Schweine vor irgendwelchen neunziger Jahre Windows Rechnern und äh und und,
und äh benutzen die nach wie vor wie Schreibmaschinen. Und dann wunderst du dich, dass du dieses Land nicht digitalisiert bekommst, ne. Das ist wirklich und das wird halt nicht funktionieren durch,
D Mail oder irgendeine ID Wallet oder was du nicht alles für einen äh Scheiß da äh bauen kannst, ja? Zumal.
Also ich meine, man darf auch nicht unterschätzen, was dieser ID Walletkram bedeutet, wenn du da irgendwie äh QR-Codes scannen oder zeigen sollst, äh
wir haben's in der letzten Sendung nur kurz angemerkt, aber in Anwesenheit einer Polizistin entsperrt man nicht sein Telefon. So,
Du weißt ja, dass die das haben wollen.
Mhm.
Und das ist wirklich, wirklich halt bitter, aber wie du schon sagtest, so was man hier eigentlich also wenn man dieses Land digitalisieren möchte und seinen riesigen Kropf an, an, an, an Bürokratie und Verwaltung, dann muss man als allererstes
den digitalisieren. Und dann muss man sich überlegen, okay,
jetzt bin ich ja ganz blöd, was haben wir hier für Ansprüche, was haben wir hier? Ne, was sind die Prozesse, die wir am häufigsten machen? Wie können wir die sinnvoll digital abbilden.
Was machen wir da für eine äh User Journey? Wie sichert man das ab
mit ganz normalen Technologien, die seit seit Jahrzehnten etabliert sind und funktionieren, ja, für die wir schon einen Vertrauensanker haben, mit unserem ähm.
Mit unserem äh äh mit unserer EID und dann bist du fertig. Und das kannste kannst du so richtig schön machen. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem,
stattdessen sachste, ey wie können wir
eine eine Infrastruktur, die Millionen oder Milliarden gekostet hat mit diesen E-IDs, wie können wir da durch eine App ersetzen? Durch eine fucking App, ich ich habe gerade äh ich habe gerade ein neues Telefon, Tim, ne,
ich bin jetzt und das ich bin jetzt hier seit Tagen damit beschäftigt meine zweiten Faktoren umzuziehen,
So und jetzt soll ich demnächst verliere ich ein Telefon und dann äh kann ich mich auf einmal nicht mehr ausweisen oder was? Das ist doch alles nicht für eine Mark mitgedacht.
Das ist eine totale Katastrophe. Und ähm ja, machen wir uns nichts vor. Es wird noch sehr, sehr, sehr lange dauern. Und man kann nur äh hoffen, dass jetzt irgendwie diese alten Generationen, die einfach auch diesen mentalen
Zugang zu diesen Technologien so noch überhaupt nicht gefunden haben, möglichst lange ferngehalten werden jetzt von diesem Regierungsgeschäft, weil es geht einfach so nicht weiter. Es ist einfach,
es ist wirklich nicht mehr zu ertragen und wir haben auch überhaupt gar keine Lust mehr dadrüber zu reden, weil es einfach alles so furchtbar schlimm ist.
Mein Gott, man freut sich schon über Sachen, das das ist schon peinlich, dass man sich darüber freut.
Worüber hast du dich denn gefreut?
Ich habe immer irgendeine Kleinigkeit mal tatsächlich funktioniert. Ähm.
Drüber nachdenken, also irgendwas ähm was hatte ich da zuletzt? Ach nee, das war nur jemand anders, hat mir gesagt, dass.
Er sein Auto zulass, seine ummelden konnte, irgendwie tatsächlich mit mit Personalausweis all die online und so weiter. Das ging natürlich in Berlin, in Berlin geht's aber natürlich nicht und hier ist immer noch
so eher die Situation, dass du froh sein musst, wenn du überhaupt in den nächsten sechs Wochen mal einen Termin kriegst. Für überhaupt irgendwas.
Nee, aber ich weiß, du hast Recht, also solche Geschichten hört man. Also da da gibt's Gerüchte, dass es einen äh einen funktionierenden digitalen Prozess zur Ummeldung eines KFZ gäbe. Das habe ich auch schon gehört.
In anderen Bundesländern. Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, da muss man äh auf dem ist das auf dem äh auf dem Fahrzeugpapieren so sowas freirubbeln, ne.
Da rubbelt man was ab, so ein äh so ein Hologramm, dann ist das da ist das Dokument ungültig und und die Zahl, die da drunter steht, kann man dann zum Abmelden nutzen oder ummelden.
Ja, habe ich also da gibt es, da gibt's fantastische Geschichten.
Die aber die eher so, ne, so als urbane äh Legenden, ne. Also jeder kennt einen, der von einem erzählt, der dessen ehemaliger Mitbewohner.
Kennt, der das schon mal gesehen hat.
Ja, es sind einfach äh digitale Märchen aus tausend und einer Nacht.
Okay. Ah, schön. Äh also tolle Wallet-ID. Ähm äh ich habe ich habe die App noch, ja, super.
Und es ist wirklich, also es ist katastrophal äh diese diese Kommunikation dann eben sozusagen also jetzt so oh ja wir sind
Das war zu innovativ und das ist zusammengebrochen unter der Nachfrage und die Kritik des CCC nehmen wir ernst. So, du,
du kannst nicht eine Applaunchen, die von paar Freiwilligen innerhalb von paar Stunden zerpflückt wird, mit mit irgendwie.
Eklatanten Lächerlichkeiten.
Wo dann auch noch herauskommt, du wusstest von denen, du hast den Mist trotzdem gelauncht und dann setzen sie sich auf irgendein Podium und sagen, boah sind wir geil und innovativ. Das ist wirklich das geht so nicht. Es tut mir leid, Freunde, so nicht.
Was übrigens auch nicht geht ist.
Frontex, wir haben wir haben ja hier schon ähm ein paar Mal davon berichtet, dass ja frag den Staat ähm.
Anfragen an ähm.
An Frontex gestellt hat und äh Frontex dann tatsächlich gesagt hat, okay, das kostet jetzt Geld, was ihr hier von uns wolltet und ähm.
Äh die haben dann, also Frontex hat 152 Euro äh gefordert von frag den Staat und ähm jetzt,
wurde dann von Seiten des Europäischen Parlamentes gesagt,
das solle diese Geldforderung fallen lassen. Also Frontex soll das nicht tun, ja? Ähm.
Und der haben also äh quasi das Parlament selber hat gesagt, so macht das nicht. Und ähm.
Zwar hat das Parlament das äh offiziell gefordert, einmal im, wo ist es?
Und im Juni.
Genau, im April und im Juni.
Und wir halten auch darüber berichtet, dass sie ursprünglich nämlich äh23.700 Euro haben wollten, dann haben wir gegen geklagt und dann hat das äh europäische Gericht gesagt, okay,
Ihr müsst die Forderung auf mehr als die Hälfte reduzieren, also nämlich äh
die 23.700 sind überzogen und ungerechtfertigt. Dann haben sie die eben runtergekürzt auf äh zehntausendfünfhundertzwanzig Euro sechsundsiebzig. Dann hat das Europäische Parlament gesagt, mehrmals lastet sein
ja, lasst die einfach in Ruhe, weil ähm ihr ähm.
Habe quasi einen Chilling-Effekt hier gegen diese äh äh gegen diese äh Initiative von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern, die ja einfach nur etwas von euch gefragt haben, ja? Siebenundachtzig.
Und so, ja genau, darum ging's ja auch.
So, 87.000 Bürgerinnen äh und über 40 Menschen Bürgerrechtsorganisationen haben Frontex aufgefordert, diese Einschüchterungsversuche einzu.
Frontex ignoriert das aber und ähm jetzt hat sie,
tatsächlich äh die letzte Mahnung gesendet und dann haben sie, so ist das ja nun mal, ne, also,
Dieses Gerichtsurteil kannst, du kannst das ja vollstrecken lassen, ja? Und ähm sie haben also jetzt gesagt, sie wollen diese zehntausendfünfhundertzwanzig Euro sechsundsiebzig haben. Soll natürlich sagen, Frontex ist eine Agentur, die hat ja Milliarden.
Ne? Das heißt, sie haben natürlich überhaupt nicht dieses Geld, also die die brauchen dieses Geld nicht
Und die, das sind ja auch virtuelle Kosten für die, aber die Vorder ist natürlich ein, um frag den Staat, die eben nicht Milliarden haben, sondern mit
tausenden oder hunderttausenden Euro im Jahr arbeiten müssen. Ähm
tausenden oder 100.000 Euro im Jahr arbeiten müssen, um denen halt äh zu schaden
Ähm da wird man also jetzt heute noch im Laufe des Tages äh sehen können, weil frag den Staat hat sich dann entschieden, hat gesagt, na, so eine unpersönliche Überweisung wäre ja schade. Also äh fahren wir mal mit dem Bargeld dahin und bringen das in Brüssel im Büro vorbei,
das kann man eben auf dem Twitter-Account verfolgen, wie dann frag den Staat, ja, diese diese Strafe,
an äh Frontex Auszeit, gibt's schon Bilder von Ahnen mit mit dem Bargeld und äh einem Köfferchen haben sie sich da zusammen fotografiert. Ich glaube, das ist Luisa und Arne sitzen da mit mitm Geldkoffer, den sie jetzt an Frontex übergeben.
Hashtag.
Ja, also ist äh äh ich meine, natürlich ist das auch bitter, ja, aber okay. So mal verlierst du auch ein Gerichtsverfahren.
Und natürlich ist das auch wieder eine Möglichkeit,
äh äh oder ein ein Anlass daran zu erinnern, das fragt den Staat sehr gerne mit Spenden unterstützt werden kann und ja, mal
verlierst du auch ein Gerichtsverfahren. Insgesamt und dabei aber nicht vergessen, dass die halt sehr viele Gerichtsverfahren gewinnen. Und hier eine Forderung äh von 23 auf zehn runterzukürzen, ist ja auch schon mal ein Erfolg, ja.
Henriette Litta twittert dazu, du weißt, dass du bei einer einzigartigen NGO arbeitest, wenn du bei der Bank um 10.000 Euro in möglichst kleinen Scheinen fragst.
Ja, man kriegt natürlich leider sowas so viel nicht so so schnell in Münzen, ne. Hm, das wäre natürlich noch besser gewesen.
Ja. Na ja.
Ähm ja dann das waren glaube ich so die die das war die Nachrichtenlage. Ähm.
Eine gibt's aber noch.
Eine gibt's noch. Äh wir haben vor ein paar Tagen dann äh ankündigen müssen. Ich glaube am Freitag haben wir das gemacht.
Also nicht wir, sondern der CCC.
Ja genau, der genau, der CC, also in dem Fall wir, der CCC. Ähm.
Dass es dieses Jahr keinen Kongress in Leipzig geben wird. Und ähm wir haben da jetzt mal, wir wollen da gar nicht also es gibt da quasi nicht einen konkreten.
Sondern einfach eine Reihe an Punkten und die
sagen wir mal von der logistischen Leistung so einen Kongress zu machen inklusive der Hürden, die jetzt zum Beispiel äh,
und äh Hygieneauflagen angehen, dass wir festgestellt haben, die Bedingungen, die wir,
die notwendig zu erfüllen wären, um eine Veranstaltung mit, sagen wir mal, ungefähr zehn.000 Leuten oder 17.000 Leuten oder vielleicht auch nur achttausend Leuten
in Leipzig durchführen zu können, würden eben.
Den Geist der Veranstaltung nachhaltig zerstören. Du hättest dann eben nicht einen Kongress, sondern du hättest halt den Corona-Kongress mit den langen Warteschleifen, mit Datenerfassung und und anderen Schwierigkeiten,
die einfach insgesamt dem größeren Teil des Orga-Teams und das ist ja ein relativ großes Team mit sehr vielen einzelnen Gruppierungen.
Äh gesagt hat, so das ist es dann nicht wert, das zu machen.
Ähm diesen Aufwand zu treiben, das würde wir hätten am Ende keine keine Sekunde Kongressfeeling, sondern eben eine eine.
Die ganze Zeit nur so einen Affentanz.
Genau, die ganze Zeit Affentanz und die ganze Zeit Auflagen und Probleme und äh du würdest diese diese Situation nicht vergessen können. Und das ist eben durchaus etwas anderes als jetzt zum Beispiel bei den
Open Air Veranstaltungen im Sommer. Da ist es ja dann streckenweise mal gelungen durch äh Testkonzepte, ne, durch Impfungen und sowas, dass sie dann gesagt haben, okay, hier zack,
einmal alle Leute testen und dann gibt's hier zwei Tage Party, alle PCR getestet, dann geht's wieder nach Hause, ne. Das sind ja umsetzbare Konzepte.
Weil sie eben auch an der frischen Luft stattfinden und im Sommer und die Leute campen und so weiter. Aber ein Kongress in Leipzig findet eben im Winter statt
da müssen die Menschen das Gelände auch täglich wieder verlassen und durch die Stadt reisen und,
wie gesagt, es geht dann äh am Ende für jedes einzelne, für jede einzelne Anforderung hätte man eine Lösung finden können, aber im gesamtgefüge.
Sind es dann einfach zu viele, als dass es, als dass du sagen könntest, unter diesen Bedingungen können wir einen Kongress machen. Und deswegen wird es also kein,
Präsenz Event in Leipzig geben.
Es wurde aber schon auch äh vor einigen Monaten angekündigt, dass die Gruppe äh remote Event natürlich äh motiviert ist,
ein Angebot zu machen. Und in welcher Form dieses gemacht wird.
Und äh ne, was was da vielleicht sich noch realisieren lässt, das wird, denke ich mal, in den nächsten Wochen dann gemeinsam erarbeitet, aber äh nach Leipzig fahren äh wird, wird nicht stattfinden.
Meine, du hast das jetzt vor allem und auch nachvollziehbarer Weise, vor allem aus der Perspektive der,
Orga geschildert, ne? Ich meine, der der Kongress ist extrem auf alle Freiwilligen äh angewiesen und selbst ähm wenn man jetzt mal diese Aspekte einer inneren Kernorga
Ja, also Leute, die sich, ja, auch alle freiwillig sind, aber die das,
viel früher annehmen, sehr viel mehr im Vorfeld arbeiten, auch die Durchführung des Kongresses selbst hängt ja dann auch sehr
von den Engeln ab, von Leuten, die sich äh freiwillig melden und auch da kann man überhaupt nicht sagen, wie viele Leute sich überhaupt noch für so ein Event entscheiden würden.
Genauso kann man, glaube ich, auch derzeit überhaupt nicht sagen, wie viele Leute überhaupt die Bereitschaft hätten, jetzt ein Indoor-Event, Ende Dezember.
Durchzuführen, zumal ja auch,
die Coronalage zu dem Zeitpunkt auch so recht nicht äh vorhersehbar ist. Also es ist wirklich eine Vielzahl von aus meiner Sicht sehr nachvollziehbaren Gründen, die es einfach vollkommen unmöglich machen und wir hoffen alle,
das Problem nächstes Jahr dann weg ist, aber jetzt kommt es einfach noch zu früh.
Und ja, damit das Problem weg ist, äh kann ich nur noch mal daran erinnern, ist es sinnvoll, wenn man sich impfen lässt,
wenn man jetzt schon mal langsam auch in Richtung äh Boosterimpfung blickt. Und wenn man vielleicht noch verbleibende Ungeimpfte,
auch nochmal sich mit denen darüber unterhält, was denn vielleicht
für sie auch sinnvoll wäre. Ich hab mich jetzt in letzter Zeit in der letzten Sendung ja schon ein bisschen oder war das die Vorletzte mal mein Unmut mit den Impfverweigerern
zum Ausdruck gebracht habe, äh noch einige Gespräche geführt, einige Hörerinnen haben sich dann auch per Mail gemeldet, ein bisschen diskutiert. Äh die Sache ist halt so,
bei aller Liebe, es gibt äußerst äußerst wenige Gründe, sich nicht zu impfen und ähm.
Also es gibt viele Gründe, aber keine Guten.
Äußerst wenige äh respektable Gründe, sich nicht zu impfen und,
wer die Menschen, die halt über Risiken argumentieren, denen muss man eben auch leider sein, so dann dann schau dir das Risiko einer Infektion an. Und äh selbst wenn, also ich persönlich fand das,
Für mich war dieser Moment der Impfung, was weiß ich, so einer der schönsten und wichtigsten meines Lebens in den letzten Jahren, ja? Und dann zu sehen, dass es irgendwelche Menschen gibt, die die dieses, die das schmähen und irgendwie, sage ich mal, in ihrer individuellen.
Risikoabwägung tatsächlich denken, dass sie ein.
Risikovermeidungsverhalten zeigen würden, wenn sie sich nicht impfen lassen,
Da muss man halt ganz einfach sagen, bis auf die wenigen gesundheitlichen Gründe, wo das irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen, mir fällt noch nicht mal einer ein, ne? Wo es angemessen ist, sich nicht zu impfen,
ist es immer riskanter, also quasi man geht auf jeden Fall das größere Risiko ein, nicht geimpft zu sein. Und ähm,
mit für die Gesellschaft so, ich meine, wir könnten sehr viel besser dastehen. Und es ist ja jetzt leider so, dass die Gelehrten
Deutschland dann doch eine relativ unschöne Zeit äh vorhersagen, weil die Impfquote noch nicht ausreichend hoch ist. In den USA habe ich jetzt letztens gesehen.
Dort äh sind jetzt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wieder ein paar hunderttausend Leute gestorben von den Toten.
97 Prozent ungeimpft. Ja und jetzt das ist jetzt wieder, wenn wir das letzte Mal auch schon drüber gesprochen, diese Prozentverteilung sind immer,
hochkomplex, aber wenn du, wenn man, man muss immer gucken, ne, das sind ja abhängige Wahrscheinlichkeiten, wenn du in einer, wenn du.
In einer Gesellschaft, sagen wir mal, sechzig Prozent geimpft hast, ja und vierzig ungeimpft,
und dann nimmst du die Toten und bei den Toten sind ihm aber siebenundneunzig umgeimpft. Da musst du ja gucken, dass diese Geimpften, die kommen ja noch noch dazu aus einer sehr viel größeren,
Grundgesamtheit. Ja, das heißt, dieser der Schutz durch die Impfung vor schweren Verlauf und Tod ist also quasi, ne.
Im Zehn- bis Hundertfachen äh Bereich von was das, was das Risiko betrifft, ne. Da muss man irgendwie keine Sekunde drüber nachdenken, ähm sich impfen zu lassen. Und.
Das tut mir auch wirklich dann leid für Leute, die äh die die der da ernsthaft sagen, ach geil, ich gehe jetzt in den Winter 21, einer tödlichen Pandemie ungeimpft.
Und beschwere mich, was weiß ich, dass ich nicht ins Fußballstadion reinkomme oder was die dann, was diese Leute dann für Sorgen haben, ne.
Tut's mir um die Leute, die äh wirklich einen,
ganz anderen Grund haben dann äh Intensivpflege zu brauchen, weil sie gerade einen Unfall haben oder äh sonst irgendeinen Vorfall, aber dann keine Plätze vorfinden, weil alles mit Ungeimpften Vollidioten äh da ist,
So und das, das ist irgendwie das, was mich am meisten ärgert. In gewisser Hinsicht könnte man jetzt ja auch schon sagen, so ey, okay, wenn ihr irgendwie nicht in der Lage seid, da äh äh eins plus eins zusammenzuzählen und einfach mal die die absolut.
Nicht anzuzweifelnde Faktenlage des letzten anderthalb Jahres wissenschaftlicher Forschung irgendwie nicht nicht verstehen wollt, gut, dann geht ihr irgendwie auf eigenes Risiko, aber leider ist es ja nicht so, sondern ihr gefährdet einfach damit,
alle
insbesondere die Leute, die wirklich die Unterstützung der Krankenhäuser dringend brauchen, denn das sind alles vermeidbare Fälle. Kostenlos, vermeidbar, problemlos, vermeidbar mit einem Zeitaufwand, der überhaupt nicht der, der,
der Erwähnung wert ist und ähm dementsprechend ja macht das jetzt bitte äh ich habe keine Lust mehr darüber zu diskutieren.
Ja, es ist wirklich, ja. Muss man leider so sagen. Oh Mann. Tja, und dann könnt ihr auch wieder zum Kongress, nächstes Jahr vielleicht.
Genau vielleicht. Das ist jetzt äh das Ende dieser Sendung.
Ist das Ende. Ihr habt äh,
Ihr wisst, wie ihr eure Prozesse digitalisieren müsst. Ihr wisst, dass es kein kein Präsenzkongress geben wird. Das heißt nicht, dass es nicht ein Alternativprogramm geben wird.
Vielleicht sogar auch irgendwo vor Ort. Ähm.
Ihr wisst, warum man trotzdem keine digitalen Wahlen haben möchte. Und äh euer Zeugnis ist in der Blockchain.
Und ihr wisst, nächste Woche werdet ihr wieder von uns hören und dann äh freuen wir uns schon auf euch. Bis dahin sagen wir tschüss und bis bald.
Ja und dann äh machen wir nächstes Mal auch wieder ein bisschen Feedback. So, bis dahin, tschau, tschau.